SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
COME TO ORDER. HI TO BEGIN
WITH- LET ME SAY ABOUT WELCOME
EVERYONE I'M GOING TO MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES THAT WE
HAVE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK. DURING THE PAN.
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
ON IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT. THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. TODAY ALSO. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER. IS. 844-291-4185 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. THREE TWO
SIX SIX ONE EIGHT EIGHT. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS THAT ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW ONLINE TOOL SO.
AGAIN PLEASE BE PATIENT. SO
EVERYONE COULD BE HEARD AND WE
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE. AND SO
IMPORTANTLY- ON BEHALF OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER I'M GOING TO ASK
ALL SPEAKERS COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY N. AS
PRACTICE HAS SHOWN I WILL
INTERRUPT YOU IF YOU ARE I
TALKING TOO FAST. TO IMPLORE
YOU TO SLOW DOWN GIVE YOU A
MINUTE TO READJUST AND DO THAT.
AND SO FORGIVE ME IN ADVANCE IF
I HAVE TO DO THAT BUT AGAIN WE
WANT TO GET YOUR TESTIMONY AND
I WANT OUR STATE NOT REFER TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S ACTUAL AGENDA
WE MUST ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND- FOR MEMBERS OUT HERE AND
THE PUBLIC LET ME JUST LET YOU
KNOW IN ADVANCE THAT SENATOR
GROVE IS ALSO COVERING THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE TODAY SO YOU
WILL SEE HER COMING GO SHE'S
USUALLY VERY GOOD AT THAT AND
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
KNOW SHE IS AND WILL BE IN
ATTENDANCE AND- WE WILL
ACCOMMODATE HER COMINGS AND
GOINGS. BUT JUST SO THE PUBLIC
IS AWARE OF WHY THAT IS THE
CASE SO WITH THAT OUR MIND
MEMBERS TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL OUR ROLE. GROVE KAMLAGER.
YEAH KAMLAGER HERE LAYERED HERE
THIRD HERE BATES HERE BATES
HERE ATKINS HERE IS HERE THANK
YOU SO HARD TO WITH A VERY-
QUICK ITEM WHICH WE WILL LEAVE
OPEN IN THE ROLE FOR SENATOR
GROWTH I'D LOVE A MOTION TO. ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES OF I WELL I HEARD
OUR VICE CHAIRWOMAN FIRST SORRY
CENTER LAYERED- SO WITH THAT
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER HIGH LAYERED. HI THERE I
BATES. BATES AYE ATKINS HI AND
WE WILL THE ROLE OPEN SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU- AND NOW I
IT'S- A TO GO TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE ITEM ONE A. AND THAT
WOULD BE THE NOMINEE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE HISTORIC
APPOINTMENT OF THE HONORABLE
ROB BONTA J. D. AS THE NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND AS WE START
AND AS I WELCOME HIM LET ME
JUST SAY- COLLEAGUES WE WERE
JUST HERE IN JANUARY TO
CONSIDER THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENT OF OUR NEW
SECRETARY OF STATE. THE FACT IS
THAT APPROVING THE REPLACEMENT
OF A STATEWIDE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER IS A RARE EXPERIENCE
AND A TREMENDOUS RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE RULES COMMITTEE AND FOR
THE SENATE. THAT'S ESPECIALLY
TRUE GIVEN THE OFFICE WE'RE
DRESSING AND THE TIMES WE ARE
IN. OBVIOUSLY POLICE REFORM AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE ARE NEEDED
MORE THAN EVER HATE CRIMES ARE
ON THE RISE ESPECIALLY THOSE
TARGETING MEMBERS OF THE AAPI
COMMUNITY ASSAULTS ARE BEING
CONTINUALLY LAUNCHED ON OUR
RIGHTS. TO VOTE OUR BASIC RIGHT
TO LIVE OUR LIVES AS WHO WE ARE.
SO WITH THAT GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS TAPPED OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB BONTA TO SERVICE OUR NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL. SO WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD AND WE WILL HEAR
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA ON
HIS THOUGHTS FOR THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT JOB DURING
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES. AND
WITH THAT I JUST WANT TO
WELCOME YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
WELCOME MEMBERS OF YOUR FAMILY.
WHO ARE HERE WITH YOU TODAY AND
LET YOU MAKE SOME OPENING
COMMENTS AND THEN WE WILL GO
RIGHT TO QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
FROM THE SENATORS WELCOME.
THANK YOU MALBROUGH TEN MADAM
CHAIR COLLEAGUES STAFF AND I
TELL MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY THANK
YOU FOR THAT THE WARM WELCOME
MADAM PRO TEM OF THE WELCOME TO
MY FAMILY. I WANT TO THANK
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THE FAITH
AND THE TRUST HE HAS PLACED IN
ME IT'S A AWESOME
RESPONSIBILITY IN A DEEP HONOR
I ALSO WANT TO THANK MY WIFE
MIA MY PARTNER IN LIFE MY
PARTNER AND SERVICE WHO'S HERE
TODAY ALSO I WANT TO THANK MY
KIDS- I HAVE THREE OF THEM THE
OLDEST OF THEM REINA IS HERE.
AT TODAY'S WELL AND LASTLY I
WANT TO THANK MY PARENTS WARREN
AND CYNTHIA THE BILL HERE TODAY
AS WELL. AND MY PARENTS ARE
WHERE MUCH TO. STARTS THEY ARE
BOTH ACTIVISTS TO THE- FIERCE
FORCE FOR FAIRNESS. AND THEIR
FOR JUSTICE HAS BEEN HARDWIRED.
INTO WHO I AM. AFTER BODIES MY-
HEADED TO SAY ALRP HOW AS A
CALL STUDENT TO STAND WITH
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR. AN
ORGAN FOR VOTING RIGHTS. AND
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AS A YOUNG
FAMILY WE MOVED TO LAZAR'S THE
HEADQUARTERS FOR THE UNITED
FARM WORKERS OF AMERICA IN
ATTACHED TO MOUNTAINS OUTSIDE
OF BAKERSFIELD. MY PARENTS HAVE
BEEN RECRUITED TO HELP FILIPINO
AND LATINO FARM WORKER. WORKERS
ADVOCATE FOR BETTER WAGES AND
WORKING CONDITIONS. AND THEY
WORK ALONGSIDE LAURA SWETA SAID
THERE CHAVEZ AND PHILIP
VERACRUZ. MOST ALL WHAT HAS
STUCK WITH ME ARE THE LESSONS
ABOUT A QUALITY THAT LA PAZ
TAUGHT ME. IN THE DIDN'T MATTER
IF YOU DATA SAID SETS JOB IS.
FOR MIGRANT FARMWORKER. IT
DIDN'T MATTER YOU'RE A FILIPINO.
CHICANO BLACK OR WHITE EVERYONE
SAW IN IN THE- AND WANTED IT.
OUR FAMILY LET THE PAST WHEN IT
WAS TIME FOR MY- AND ME. TO
START SCHOOL BUT THOSE EARLY
LOW DON. THAT AN INJUSTICE A
ONE. IS AN AND JUST AGAINST ALL
ITS WIDEST TO BECOME A ATTORNEY
THE FOR THOSE WHO ARE BEEN
WRONG WE'RE SCARED FOR HER WHO
ARE MISTREATED AND NEEDED
SOMEONE TO FOR THEM. AND IT'S
NOT FOR JUSTICE ALL CAL. THAT
MOTIVATES ME TODAY. AFTER
GRADUATING FROM LOS AND
SPENDING A TIME AND PRACTICE. I
DECIDED TO PRACTICE THE P. FULL
TIME. JOINING THE SAN FRANCISCO.
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. BY THE
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR NEARLY
A DECADE. BEFORE ULTIMATELY
JOINING YOU ALL IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. FOR THE PAST EIGHT
PLUS YEARS I'VE BEEN EXCITED TO
WAKE UP EVERY DAY I HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING WORKING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE. AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE. I'VE BEEN PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH EACH OF YOU TO
PASS A NUMBER. OF BIG REFORMS
AND TO RIGHT HISTORIC WRONGS.
TO REPAIR A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. TO TAKE ON BIG
POLLUTERS. AND TO PROTECT
RENTERS HOMEOWNERS CONSUMERS.
AND WORKERS. I'M PARTICULARLY
PROUD OF THE WORK WE'VE DONE
AND ARE DOING TO COMBAT HATRED
AND HELP VICTIMS OF HATE CRIME
SO IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE NEED LEADERS
WHO WILL BUILD BRIDGES. WITH
THOSE HAVE BEEN PERSECUTED
OTHER THAN AND TARGETED THAT
WILL BE ONE OF MY FIRST
PRIORITIES IF I HAVE THE HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE. OF BEING
CONFIRMED AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE
TARGETED BY THE FORCES OF HATE.
ARE PROTECTED AND THAT THOSE
WHO USE HATE VIOLENCE. ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. STRENGTHENING OUR
OUR DEFENSES AGAINST HATE ISN'T
THE ONLY PROBLEM WE FACE. THERE
ARE STILL TOO MANY WHO ARE
WRONG IN CALIFORNIA. TOO MANY
COULD BECOME VICTIMS OF
TRAFFICKING. ABUSE AND
MISTREATMENT TOO MANY WHO ARE
TREATED UNFAIRLY BY THE MANY
BROKEN PARTS OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND DESERVE
MORE JUSTICE. MORE HUMANITY.
AND A SECOND CHANCE. TOO MANY
WHO'VE BEEN CHEATED BY BIG
CORPORATIONS OR LIED TO. AS
PART OF AN ORGANIZED SCAM. OR
FRAUD. AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THESE FIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
FIGHTS WILL BE MY FIGHTS. I
KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES FACING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BUT I'M
ALSO KEENLY AWARE OF THE
DEDICATION OF THE CAREER STAFF
IN THE TREMENDOUSWORK THAT IS
DONE BY THE DEPARTMENT. EVERY
DAY. THESE ARE SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST LEGAL MINDS IN
HARD TO PROTECT OUR FAMILIES.
CALIFORNIA DOJ MUST BE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IF USES MORE
JUSTICE. FOR HUMANITY. MORE
FAIRNESS. AND MORE SAFE. INTO
OUR INSTITUTIONS. I HOPE TO
FURTHER ADVANCE THOSE EFFORTS
AND SOLIDIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S REPUTATION. AS A
NATIONAL VANGUARD FOR REFORM.
THE FACT THAT THEY YOU AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I'M GOING
TO LOOK AND SEE IF MY VICE
CHAIRMAN WOULD LIKE TO KICK US
OFF. LET ME CORRECT THAT I
DON'T OFFICE ADVISED IF I DID I
MEAN MY CHAIR. I CATCH IT HI
I'M I MIGHT HAVE BEEN IN MY
HEAD. I SENATOR A Q. WELL I
WELCOME IN MEMBER OF BY SEEM TO
BE I MISSING NOT MISTER TURNING
GENERAL- WE HAD A- GOOD CALL.
YESTERDAY ON A CO OF AYE THAT
CHILD WERE ON. I THINK PRIORITY
ME ON HAND TO. AND DON'T ENJOY
DOING YOU FOLLOW THE CA. BUT I
DID MANAGE THAT I LIKE YOU TO
ADDRESS THOSE ON THE IN THE-
FORUM ONE THE- OF. AND I DID
MANAGE THAT IN NOW TO EIGHTEEN
SENATE NIELSEN AND I AM WITH.
ATTORNEY TO SERRA TIMES. OVER
FAILURE ABOUT ARE ABLE GROWING
OUT OF THE BACK IS GROWING. A
TO THIRTEEN ON THINK WE'RE OUT
AND ABOUT TWENTY THREE THEN ON
THE SIGNAL AMOUNT OF AND
ACTUALLY TO DO THERE ARE SOME.
CLOSE TO MILLION DOLLAR SITTING
CAN PUT FORWARD FOR THAT
PROGRAM TO RAINY AND NOW THE
WHO ARE DETERMINED TO- YOU KNOW
DANGEROUS. AND THEREFORE NOT
SHOULD NOT HAVE- A MONTH THAT
THEY RAINY- IN ON TEN THOUSAND
CASES PLUS AMOUNTS COME BACK
ONTO THE REGISTER SO THERE'S A
COMMUNITY. ISSUE TOO WITH THE
GUN SHOP SO. CERTAINLY THE GUN
SHOW AND HAD. THE WAY TO TRAP
THESE. SO I. UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE'S HAS TO BE A PLAN. AND
ASSIST FROM THE- FINANCE- TO
ACTUALLY DO THE- BECAUSE IT'S
GROWN AND ARE CALM. REMEMBER
WHAT ABOUT OF THEM SHOOTING
THAT WE'VE ON THE PERPETRATOR
OF THOSE ARE CLEAR CLASSIFIED
AS THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT. HAVE
ANY POSSESSION OF WEAPONS%
SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN GIVEN YOU
KNOW ON A LICENSE FOR THAT UNIT
HAD HAD ONE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TAKEN AWAY AND ALSO THEIR GUNS.
ARE POSSESSED. BY THE STATE SO
LET'S BEGIN WITHOUT BECAUSE ME
THAT'S BEEN A TOP PRIORITY THE
WAY BACK TO WHEN I FIRST.
ARRIVED THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR AND ME START
BY SAYING. THAT I APPRECIATED
THAT THE- THAT HAD AND- ON THIS
ISSUE. NO ONE SHOULD FEEL GONE
BY. WHERE THEY GO TO SCHOOL
THEY WORK WHERE THEY- CAN. GUN
VIOLENCE IS AMERICA'S DISEASE
IF SIXTEEN WITH THROUGH AND
WE'VE- BLOEMEN. TOO MANY MASS
SHOOTINGS AN THEY ARE
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM ONE
AREA WHERE- ALTHOUGH THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PROPOSAL PUT FORWARD BY THIS IS
ONE OF THE BEEN A LOT OF BY
SUPPORT. CAN IT'S AN AREA WHERE.
I WANT WHAT YOU WANT. WHAT WE
ALL WHICH IS TO READ THE NUMBER
OF CASES ACTIVE CASES ON THE
APPS SYSTEM. AS QUICKLY AND AS
ACCURATELY AND THOROUGHLY AS
POSSIBLE. AND IT IS IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU SAID THAT THE- OPS THE
DATABASE IS DYNAMIC IT'S NOT
STATIC- THERE'S TEN THOUSAND
NEW CASES THAT COME IN PER YEAR
I BELIEVE YOU MAY HAVE SAID FOR
MONTHS I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
THAT IT IS PER YEAR. AND ON
AVERAGE ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
ACTIVE CASES THAT ARE CLEARED
FOR YEARS WHILE THE HERO SAY
WAS A SLOWER YEAR- THE STATURE
BECAUSE OF CALVET THAT THE WAY
THAT THE CASE IS CLEARED IS YOU
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY LOCATION
WHERE SOMEONE IS KNOWN TO HAVE
A- A WEAPON I BASED ON THE DATA
THAT THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE ETFE
KNOCK ON THE DOOR MAKE A VISIT
AND TRY TO REMOVE THOSE WEAPONS
FROM THAT PERSON. SO THESE ARE
THESE ARE IN PERSON CONGREGATE-
ACTIONS THAT WERE IMPACTED BY
COLD. WE HAVE SOME CHALLENGES-
THE GENEROUS BY. THE PROPOSAL
AND ALLOCATE THAT WERE GIVE TO.
THE DEPARTMENT OF. AND ONE OF
THEM ARE PARKED. IT IT'S A- NOT
AS AS FLUENT AND AS FLUID AND A-
EASY USE AS IT SHOULD A LITTLE
PUNK TO BE A- AND EVER. MANUAL
AT TIMES AND WE CAN'T CALL UP
THE DATA AND IF A QUICK
ENTITIES AS WE LIE. TOM AND SO
WE GOT AN FROM THAT LETTER TO.
IMPROVE THAT WANT TO WORK PHASE
TWO TO CONTINUE TO MAKE A
IMPROVEMENT WE ALSO NEED HAVE
SPECIAL AGE WHO IMPLEMENT-
THESE AND REMOVE THE GUNS OUT
OF WHO ARE ON THE LESS. AND WE
HAVE SOME VACANCIES WE NEED
MAKE SURE WE ATTRACT AND RETAIN.
WELL TRAINED EIGHT TO DO JOB SO
THOSE ARE SORT OF INTO CAL THAT
I BE HONORED WORK WITH YOU ON-
I THIS IS BEEN A HIT AND ISSUE
OF IN FOR ME AS IT BEEN FOR YOU
SENATOR BATES- SINCE THE DAY I
GOT HERE I WAS ELECTED IN
TWENTY TWELVE. AND A MONTH
AFTER MY DUE TO CANNOT HAPPEN.
SENATE BILL SCHOOL. TRAGIC
TERRA MATCH. AND AT THAT. THERE
WAS A SCENE. INVEST INTO. THE
APPS BROKE THAT LED TO. MAY.
THE BACKLOG AT THE TIME WE
AFTER REMOVED THREE YEARS LATER
AS A- AT AND- WAS A PURPOSE
ACCORDING TO A AUDITOR SO. FOR
ME PROGRESS WE ARE RE. ACTIVE
MEMBER- NAY FROM THE APPS LESS
BY IT CONTINUES TO GROW AND I
WANTED TO BE ALL TO DO IT MORE
QUICKLY ACT. I'VE HIGHLIGHTED
IT THE AND ABOUT THE HONOR
IMPROVE OF SERVING SIX AS A
TURN GENERAL I LIKE TO WORK
THOSE AND LEGISLATURE LIKE
YOURSELF IF YOU WILLING OTHER.
HEY WE HAVE A TASK I THINK WE
CAN REALLY WELL TOGETHER DELAY
THE GENERAL OFFICE TECH TO GET
UPDATES. SANTA BE FOUGHT
PARTNERS ON HOW TO GET WILL BE
WANT WHICH IS THE QUICKEST
REDUCTION THAT THAT WE CAN TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND CAL. THOSE
ARE NOT THE ESSENCE IS ME
EIGHTY A YEAR. IF IT WAS EVERY
MAN I THINK YEAH. AS WE ALL
KNOW THAT. WE DO HAVE THE ON
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE PRISON
SHUTTING DOWN- MORE-
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE ARE
PROBABLY YOU KNOW. ALMOST THEIR.
INTERESTS THEIR TRAINING THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS. HOW WOULD
YOU CAN. DOING. RECRUITMENT TO
ENSURE THAT GROUP. AS. GRAHAM
SO I THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONVINCED THAT BY ADDING STAFF
AND HAVING THE ENFORCEMENT. YOU
KNOW A REALLY RAMP UP CAN BE
ROLLED US WHICH IS REALLY
NEEDED. THAT THAT WOULD BE PART
OF YOUR PLAN GOING FORWARD. MR
WITH SECOND PART YOUR QUESTION
FIRST AND THAT IS I AGREE THAT
IT SHOULD BE. THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S BURDEN RESPONSIBILITY
TO DEMONSTRATE WHY INVESTMENTS
WILL ADD VALUE. AND THAT IF
MONIES GIVEN BY THE LEGISLATION
THE GOVERNOR- THE NEEDLE NEEDLE
WILL BE MOVED PROGRESS WILL BE
MADE- I OWE THAT TO YOU IF I
CAN I HAVE THE HONOR PRIVILEGE
OF BEING ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
ASK FOR MORE MONEY. AND I THINK
WE CAN AGREE ON PATHWAYS ABOUT
HOW TO GET THERE YOUR IDEA I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT IDEA TO
CONSIDER FOR HOW TO FILL THE
VACANCY RATE THERE'S PROBABLY
OTHER IDEAS OUT THERE AS WELL-
I DO THINK THAT ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES HAS BEEN- YOU KNOW
IF WE'VE HAD DIVERT THE
RETENTION. AND ATTRACTION CHILD
FOR SOME TIME AND IT A LITTLE
BIT OF IT IS- INSTITUTIONAL. IN
TERMS OF BEING COMPETITIVE. SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
ATTRACT FOLKS TO COME INTO
THOSE POSITIONS AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CAN'T JUST BE ANYBODY
HAS TO BE THE RIGHT PERSON WITH
THE RIGHT SKILL SET WITH THE
RIGHT TALENTS TO GET THIS JOB
DONE RIGHT. SAFELY AND-
THOROUGHLY SO. I'M OPEN TO
IDEAS AND OTHERS- BUT- THANK
YOU FOR AGREEING THAT THE
VACANCY RATE IS A CHALLENGE.
THERE IS CONCERN FROM OUR
SECOND AMENDMENT ADVOCATES ALSO
THAT A LOT OF THE FOLKS IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN ON GUN
CONTROL NOT RECOGNIZING THAT
MANY MOST PEOPLE WITHHOLD FONG
MAYBE THE 55% A MEASURE THE 2%
ON A BELL CURVE ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE THE WORST ONES WE HAVE
TO BE VERY VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE GETTING THEIR
GUNS. ILLEGALLY ANYWAY AND THEN
YOU ADD THOSE TO THOSE FOLKS
THAT DO HAVE THESE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES HUGE PROBLEM SO
WHAT IS GOING TO BE YOUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE WHO ARE
LAW ABIDING YOU KNOW GUN OWNERS
WHO ARE FEEL THAT THERE'S A
REAL ATTACK ON THEIR RIGHT FOR
SELF PROTECTION AND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT I'M SURE THAT YOU'VE
HAD YOUR MOMENT ALREADY WITH
THOSE ISSUES BUT IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO HAVE IT ON THE RECORD
AND I KNOW MY- COLLEAGUE
SENATOR- GROUP WILL BE HERE
SHORTLY WILL. PROBABLY I WANT
TO HAVE. A LITTLE MORE
EXPLANATION ON THAT. THANK YOU
THE QUESTION. I BELIEVE IN IN
COMMONSENSE GUN SAFETY POLICIES
THAT MAKE US SAFER I HAVE NO
PROBLEM A QUARREL WITH. THOSE
WHO RESPONSIBLY OWN GUNS FOR
SELF DEFENSE OR FOR SPORTING OR
HUNTING- BLOOD THAT IS NOT MY
FOCUS MY FOCUS IS ON THOSE WHO
WILL DO HARM- DOWN THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
MASS SHOOTINGS THAT HAVE TAKEN
LIVES OF OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS AND- THOSE ACROSS.
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND MY
FOCUS IS ON ENDING WITH A
EARLIER DESCRIBED AS AMERICA'S
DISEASE- THEN REDUCING THE
DEATH AND THE HURT THAT COMES
FROM FROM GUN VIOLENCE SENATE
THANK I ABSOLUTELY THINK. THAT
YOU CAN DO BOTH AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO SAY
THAT SOMEONE WHO SUPPORTIVE OF
COMMONSENSE- TEN FIFTY POLICIES
IS NECESSARILY BECAUSE OF THAT.
AGAINST THE SECOND AMENDMENT
NOT TRUE- YOU CAN HONOR THE
SECOND AMENDMENT AS I DO AND
ALSO BE IN SUPPORT OF
COMMONSENSE. GUN SAFETY
POLICIES I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THAT LET ME MOVE TO ANOTHER
AREA THAT'S OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN TO MIND TO ME AND I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED JOBS SINCE I'VE
BEEN THE LEGISLATURE WITH. THE
INCREASE IN THE OPIOID USE AND-
THE ILLEGAL DRUG TRADE I'VE HAD
A BILL- BEFORE THE- LEGISLATURE
A COUPLE OF SESSIONS ON FAT NOW
TO HAVE THE EDGE BASICALLY-
IT'S OFFENSE ENHANCEMENT WHICH
IS NOT POPULAR I LOOK AT IT IN
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE THAT IS
JUST ADDING FENTANYL TO. TO
DRUGS OF WHICH IS COOKING.
COCAINE AND TEARAWAY. WHICH ARE
SCHEDULED TO NOT HER ONE IS ONE
COCAINE A SCHEDULE TO BUT DO
HAVE SEVERE PENALTY FOR LOW
QUANTITIES THAT ARE IMPORTED
AND- PRODUCED AND IMPORTED ON
BY. LET'S SAY THE CURTAILS.
HANDLE WOULD YOU BE SUPPORTIVE
OF- THE HOBBIT NOW BEING LISTED
ON THE SCHEDULE ONE DRUGS WRITE
A LETTER OF SUPPORT ON THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE AREAS THAT WE HAVE TO. DEAL
COORDINATE WITH A AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHEN WE GET THERE
WE'LL PROBABLY HAVE A MORE.
UNITED NOW NATIONAL A DEFENSE
AGAINST THIS POISON AND IT IS
ALWAYS AN ISSUE I KNOW YOU'RE
PROBABLY VERY AWARE OF HOW
LEGAL IT IS. BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO AS WE SEE OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING
DECEIVED- THAT UNFORTUNATELY
THERE IN. TO THE DRUG CULTURE
AND GETTING HIGH. ON OPIATES
NOT UNDERSTANDING THAT THOSE
ARE NOW FENTANYL PILLS THAT
KILL THEM PRETTY INSTANTLY NOW
TO MINNESOTA RESTORATION SHUTS
DOWN IF YOU HAVE FOUND NOW. SO.
GIVE ME SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT.
FOR THE- BOB YOU ARE THE APPLE
HAS HURT TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
IN TOO MANY PROFITS NATION AND-
RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IS WORKING WITH OTHER
STATES OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. ON. A POTENTIAL
NATIONWIDE- OR MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL SETTLEMENT FIVE
TO HELP BRING ACCOUNTABILITY
AND BRING INVESTMENTS INTO
MITIGATION STRATEGIES ANTI
DETECTION PREVENTION-
STRATEGIES AND PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT WILL ADDRESS THE
VERY ISSUE THAT YOU'VE JUST
RAISED. I THINK THAT ADDICTION
DRUG ADDICTION- SHOULD SHOULD
GENERALLY. BE RESPONDED TO WITH
WITH CARE. AND COMPASSION AND
PROGRAMS- CHEN AND NOT WITH
MORE CRIMINALIZATION- BUT I
WILL I HAVE NOT LOOK AT YOUR
BILL FOR ALL THE DIFFERENT
COMPONENTS OF IT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
LOOK INTO MORE CLOSELY WITH
SOME OF THE EXPERTS AT
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
WITH THEM AS THEIR ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AND THINK MORE ABOUT
IT IN AND SHARE SOME MORE
THOUGHTS I WILL SAY THAT. ONE
UNIQUE PART ABOUT MINE PATH TO
THE NOMINATION IS THAT IT'S
BEEN THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
IT'S BEEN SERVING WITH YOU. AND
OTHER OF OUR GREAT COLLEAGUES
FOR THE LAST EIGHT PLUS YEARS.
I HAVE BENEFITTED TREMENDOUSLY
FROM THAT BECAUSE OF PEOPLE'S
PASSION AREAS AND THE THINGS
THAT I'VE LEARNED ABOUT THEIR
DISTRICTS IN THE POLICY AREAS
THAT DRIVE THEM. AND I HOPE TO
KEEP THAT. MOVING FORWARD AND
SO THAT WHEN I SAY I'M FOR TO
TALKING TO YOU MORE IN THE
FUTURE IF I AM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. I MEAN THAT BECAUSE
IT'S MY INTENT TO SEEK OUT THE
EXPERTISE IN THIS BODY. AND THE
PARTNERSHIP AND TOP
PARTNERSHIP- TO HELP ME DO MY
JOB BETTER AND HOPEFULLY FOR
ALL OF US TO SERVE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I KNOW
THAT SHE MADE A VERY
COMPELLING. DISCRETE HAD A VERY
COMPELLING DISCUSSION ON THAT
OKAY YESTERDAY WHEN WE TALKED
TO AND NOT NOT MEANS SO MUCH TO
US BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN AMONG
US. IN YOU UNDERSTAND OUR
FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE INTENT.
AND THE GOOD BECAUSE OF OUR
LEGISLATION IS SOMEHOW WHEN IT
GETS WHERE IT'S GOING IT JUST
DOESN'T EVER. YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
ALWAYS IMPLEMENTED ON THE WAY
IT WAS INTENDED TO BE AND THEN
IT DOESN'T COME BACK TO US- TO
KIND OF SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT
SO THAT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE. I
HAVE. ONE LAST QUESTION AND
I'VE BEEN INFORMED. IT WAS KIND
OF CUTE. COMMENT TO ME I HAVE A-
BILL THAT I'VE MADE IT TO YOUR
BILL BUT IS ON ELECTION
INTEGRITY SO. THE CHAIRMAN OF
THAT COMMITTEE WHOSE GOOD
FRIEND SAID YOU KOW THIS IS A
VERY PRICKLY ISSUE YOU'VE GOT.
TO AND I SAID WELL- YES WE KNOW
THAT BUT ISN'T THAT OUR JOB IS
TO AT LEAST RAISE THE
DISCUSSION AND AWARENESS IN A
IN A POSITIVE WAY AND I THINK.
IT COULD BE VERY POSITIVE
THAT'S GOING TO BE UNDER YOUR
DIRECTORS DICTION AS THE
INITIATIVE TITLE AND SUMMARY
SIGNED. LEGISLATION BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE I THINK A LOT OF
THE ISSUES REALLY DEVELOPED
ESPECIALLY ON THE PROPOSITIONS
THAT ARE. BALLOT INITIATIVES TO
YOU KNOW SUPPORTER. STOP
WHATEVER. TOP PERCENT. OF ALL
OF US HAVE AN ISSUE WITH SO.
WHAT STEPS WILL YOU TAKE TO
ENSURE THE PROCESS IS REALLY
NOT PARTISAN. AND IT'S SIMPLE
ENOUGH ACCURATE TO WHAT IT'S
DOING AND I WILL REFER BACK TO
ONE WHERE THERE WAS TE BIG
DISCUSSION ON IT WAS SB ONE THE
TAX MEASURE ON GAS. IN IT
REALLY- PEOPLE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND AFTER THEY VOTED ON
IT WHAT IT REALLY MEANT THE
MOST TO THE LATEST ONE IS PROP
NINETEEN. ON WHETHER YOU CAN
TRANSFER YOUR PROPERTY- THAT'S
CURRENTLY IN A TRUST TO YOUR
CHILDREN UNLESS THEY'RE GOING
TO LIVE IN ONE ANYWAY. AND THAT
KIND OF DISTORTED. SO I'M
GETTING THE CALLS AND YOU WOULD
TO. HAVE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON
WELL I DIDN'T KNOW AND SO WHAT
CAN YOU DO. GOING FORWARD SO
THEY DO KNOW IF THERE'S A THREE
PART. IN ON THAT PARTICULAR
THING THERE'S TWO EXCELLENT
PARTS OF THAT BILL BUT THIS
OTHER ONE. THIS CREATED ISSUES
AND MORE TIME I THINK WOULD
HELP. THAT OTHER PART OF IT.
THAT TO LIVE WHAT WOULD YOU D
TO TRY TO. YOU KNOW MAKE IT A
LITTLE CLEARER. I KEEP IT
STUPID SIMPLE IF THEY SAY. THAT
YOU CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE IT IS
LAW BUT MAKING IT MORE
INTELLIGIBLE. TO THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO READ IT FOR THE FIRST
TIME. THANK YOU FOR RAISING. AS
YOU NOTICE THE ROLE AS YOU SAY
OR THE TURN GENERAL. PREPARE
CUT ON SUMMER AND- THE RESPONSE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS TO
DO THAT FAIRLY IMPARTIALLY AND
TO CALL BALLS AND STRIKES IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO BE A
DESCRIPTIVE- INFORMATIVE. AND
ALLOW VOTERS TO KNOW WHAT THE
VOTING ON. SO YOU KNOW AS YOU
SAY USING WORDS THAT ARE AND
TERMS AND IDEAS THAT ARE AS
ACCESSIBLE AS POSSIBLE AS
INFORMATIVE AS POSSIBLE THE
VOTERS KNOWING. WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON THIS CAN BE IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I CAN COLOR
PASSED THE BATON TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR CONTINUE
QUESTIONING BUT I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR SPONSON AND CERTAINLY ALL.
YOU'VE DONE A LOT OF FUN
THINKING ON ALL OF THIS TIME
AND I THINK THAT THAT. IS A
MARK OF MINISTRATION GOING
FORWARD WE HOPE AND THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO SO THANKS. AND I
MIGHT COME BACK AFTER. YOU KNOW
WE HAVE MORE AFTER THE PUBLIC
WAY SAYS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU SENATOR-
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM CHAIR. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE- AND ALSO I
POINTED OUT TO. THE DOOR I GREW
UPIN VALLEJO WITH A VERY LARGEFILIPINO AMERICAN POPULATION
ALL OF WHOM I THINK ARE
PROBABLY VERY PROUD RIGHT NOW
BUT YOUR APPOINTMENT SO. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND I KNOW THAT
PUTS AN ADDED. PRESSURE ON YOU
FOR SUCCESS. OF IT BEING A
TRAILBLAZER IS NOT AN EASY
PLACE TO BE ALL THE TIME AND I
APPRECIATE ARE YOU MEETING WITH
ME AND WE HAVE A VERY
THOUGHTFUL TALKED AND I THOUGHT
WOULD BE GOOD TO MAYBE DRAW OUT
SOME OF THE SAME TOPICS FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT MY FUNDED STARK.
WITH THE FACT THAT I TALK THAT
I'VE HAD EXPERIENCE NOW WITH
ABOUT FIVE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S.
REMOVAL HAD A DIFFERENT
OPERATING STYLE. OTHERS SOME OF
THEM OF DECIDED HAVE BEEN TOP
DOWN OF SOME SORT OF TAKE WHAT
COMES FROM THE RANKS AND
TEMPERED A LITTLE. THE SOME
SEEM TO PUT MUCH MORE OF A
POLITICAL IMPRINT ON WHAT COMES
FROM THE RANKS. HOW WOULD YOU
VIEW THIS JOB IN TERMS OF YOUR
MANAGEMENT OR YOUR OPERATING
STYLE. I THINK. PERHAPS A
HYBRID OF THE DIFFERENT MODELS
YOU JUST DESCRIBED AND- YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE AMONG
ABSOLUTE INCREDIBLE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OF SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'VE BEEN
LUCKY TO HAVE IN THAT ROLE- I
AM DEEPLY HONORED THAT. A
NUMBER OF THEM HAVE REACHED OUT
TO PROVIDE FRIENDSHIP AND
COUNSEL AND WISDOM. AND IT FOR
ME IT IT'S A LARGE DEPARTMENT
ASIAN NOW BILLION DOLLAR
APARTMENT ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES THOUSAND
ATTORNEYS AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
BE ABLE TO SET A VISION. AND
MAKE SURE YOUR YOUR VALUES ARE
KNOWN YOUR PRIORITIES ARE CLEAR.
AND MAKE SURE YOU HAVE A GOOD
TEAM AROUND YOU TO HELP TO HELP
IMPLEMENT- I ALSO YOU KNOW I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE ATTORNEYS AND THE
INVESTIGATORS IN THE OFFICE AYE
AYE AYE WAS ONE. IN A DIFFERENT
ROLE IN THE SAN DIEGO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I DID A JOB
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT MANY OF
THE- DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
DO. SO I THINK SETTING A CLEAR
VISION I WOULD PRIORITIES
WHAT'S IMPORTANT WHAT'S LESS
IMPORTANT AND TRUSTING THE TEAM
TO IMPLEMENT- AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY KNOW. THE TRUTH WHICH
IS THAT I HAVE WOULD HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEM TO IMPLEMENT
THAT. AND I'M PROUD OF THEM IN
THEIR WORK I THINK IT'S MERELY
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THIS
REVIEW REALLY HELPFUL AND IT
SORT OF A LOAN AMOUNT LINES I
TOLD YOU THE STORY THAT. WHEN I
WAS FIRST RESOURCES SECRETARY-
I HAD TO NEGOTIATE. TO TRY TO
BRING NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA INTO THE MARINE
PROCESS. AND WAS VERY HARD THEY
WERE IN OPPOSITION IT REALLY
INVOLVES CERTAIN LEGAL
PRINCIPLES OF EQUAL PROTECTION.
AND I GOT TO SOMEBODY IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IT
WAS IN THE FIRST WEEKS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SOMEBODY
THAT NOW HAPPENS TO BE THE
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL AND-
HOPE YOU GET A CHANCE TO WORK
WITH. AND AS I EXPLAINED TO HIM
THE ISSUES OF. ON THE LEGAL
SIDE THERE'S EQUAL PROTECTION
BROUGHT. ON THE POLICY SIDE
IT'S NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
HAVE HAD HISTORIC TAKES OF FOR
SUBSISTENCE FOR CEREMONIAL
PURPOSES. AND IT'S TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF MARINE PROTECTION I
CAN HAVE THOSE RIGHTS AND
SOMEWHERE IN THE CONVERSATION
HE SAID TO ME. WHAT'S THE RIGHT
PUBLIC POLICY THING TO DO. AND
I AS I TOLD YOU IN OUR MEETING
I HAD REALLY FREQUENTLY BEEN
ASKED THAT BY AN ATTORNEY. WHO
WAS TRYING TO NEXT NAVIGATE TO
LEGAL ISSUES. HOW WILL YOU
BALANCE. WHAT YOU THINK IS ARE
THE LEGAL ISSUES YOU HAVE TO AS
YOU SAID CALL BALLS AND STRIKES
ON. WITH WHAT THE RIGHT PUBLIC
POLICY I THANK MIGHT BE. FROM
GREAT QUESTION AND IT HAS YOU
KNOW IT'S A U. TURN GENERAL'S
AN ELECTED POSITION. IT'S FOR
AN ATTORNEY- BUT BUT THERE'S
ALSO A COUPLE OF POLITICAL
COMPONENT TO IT. AND TO ME THAT
YOU KNOW. MY LEADERSHIP HAS
ALWAYS BEEN DRIVEN BY MY
VALUES- THE VALUES OF
OPPORTUNITY AND EQUITY AND
JUSTICE AND INCLUSION IN THAT
FRAMES HELLO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING. HOW IT LOOKS HI
LOOKING ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE. FIGHTING
FIGHTING FOR AND SEEING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
MAKING SURE THEY'RE NOT BEING
HEARD BYE BYE BIG POLLUTERS.
THAT IS A GOOD POLICY TO ME IF
YOU'RE HELPING PROTECT. BY THE
DISADVANTAGED VULNERABLE THE
VOICELESS FROM THE OVERREACH
FOR THE ABUSE OF THOSE WITH
POWER- YOU KNOW MAKING SURE.
THAT CORPORATIONS AREN'T.
CHEATING ARE CONSUMERS FOR
OVERSTEPPING THE BOUNDS OF
THEIR AUTHORITY TO HURT- PEOPLE
ARE VIOLATE THEIR PRIVACY- IT'S
THAT FRAMEWORK WHICH HELPS ME
DETERMINE WHAT IT'S GOOD
POLICY. AND SO POLICY IT IS
PART OF THE OFFICE I'M HAVING
PRIORITIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
BASED ON VALUES AND BASED ON A
PUBLIC POLICY. GOAL IN ORDER TO
PROTECT LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
PROTECT OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
STOP WITH CALIFORNIA'S VALUES
TO. RESTORE YOU TO PUT MORE
JUSTICE INTO OUR PROGRAM BROKEN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THOSE
ARE ALL POLICY DECISIONS THAT
ARE VALUE BASED VALUE DRIVEN.
AND OUR GUIDE- MY ROLE AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD I HAVE
THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF
BEING CONFIRMED. THAT'S REALLY
HELPFUL AND I REALLY
APPRECIATED IT SORT OF TEES.
OFF THE NEXT. TOPIC BECAUSE ONE
A YEAR YOU WILL BE IN IN
ENVIRONMENT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
LAND. WE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT AS A LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIAL IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES ALONG THE COAST WHERE
THERE WAS PROPOSED OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING. STATE ADMINISTRATION
LIKE TO FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
MARKET THE ONLY THING THAT WAS
STANDING BETWEEN US AND WHAT WE
DID WANT. FOR A FEW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS LIKE LEON PANETTA AND
JOHN VAN DE KAMP- IS THE STATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S IN A UNIQUE
POSITION BECAUSE THE HEAD OF
THE STATE AT A DIFFERENT POLICY
DIRECTION. AND YET HE WAS
ELECTED BY THE STATE AND HAD A
DISTINCT VIEW THAT HAD TO ACT
ON HIS OWN IT IN DOING THAT HOW
DO YOU SEE THAT ROLE- AND NOW
OF COURSE. THERE'S A LITTLE
MORE WHATEVER. THE EUPHEMISM
WITH ME HEGEMONY AMONG THE
STATE OFFICIALS WHERE THERE
USED TO BE A MANY MORE SWEATS
BUT HOW DO YOU SEE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO TAKE ACTION ON
THINGS. THAT THAT MIGHT. BE
WHERE YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE LEAD.
WHAT VEHICLE YOU YOU POINT OUT
TO REALLY IMPORTANT PARTS OF
THE TWENTY GENERAL'S ROLE WHICH
IS ONE. TO REPRESENT CLIENTS
DEPARTMENT CLIENT AGENCY
CLIENTS- BUT ALSO WHEN IT COMES
TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PROTECTING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES HAS. BROAD AND WIDE
SCOPE OF AUTHORITY. AND TO ACT
ON ITS OWN IN IN DEFENSE OF
OUR- ENVIRONMENT TO PROTECT OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES. TO SEEK
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. SO YOU
KNOW I LIKE TO COLLABORATE I
LIKE TO DO THINGS THAT THAT ARE
THAT ARE GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA-
BY WORKING WITH OTHERS TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THAT IS TO BE ON
THE SAME PAGE I HOPE TO AND NOT
HAVE. FRICTION OR INCONSISTENCY
AND EXECUTIVE BRANCH IMPOSSIBLE
BUT IT SOMETIMES IT'LL HAPPEN.
AND IF IT'S SOMETHING WITHIN MY
AUTHORITY- THAT IS A- AND AT
THAT TIME THE POWER TO DO AS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SHOULD BE
CONFIRMED- I WILL FOLLOW MY
VALUES. TO DO WHAT I THINK IS
RIGHT FOR THE THAT ABOUT PEOPLE
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES OF
THE STATE. AND THAT TIES
TOGETHER INTERESTINGLY THE
QUESTIONS I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE I MENTIONED. ONE
WHEN WE TALKED. THE THERE WAS A-
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GNERAL. THAT
HUNDRED. FOR THE ISSUES AT LAKE
TAHOE. AND HE WAS THE LEADER ON
MAKING SURE THAT THE RIGHT
THINGS WERE DONE AND IT MADE OF
COURSE MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS
PARTICULARLY ON ONE SIDE OF THE
STATE LINE NOT THIS ONE
COMPLETELY CRAZY. WITH IT AND
YET HE MONITORED IT THERE HAD
BEEN AN UPDATED GENERAL PLAN IN
TWENTY YEARS THERE'D BEEN ALL
THESE ISSUES AND ONE OF THE
MAJOR LEADERS. IN SORT OF FOUR
PLAYERS WAS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IN SHORT TIMES
INTO THE PREVIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT HOW YOU TAKE IN YOUR
MANAGEMENT STYLE YOU'VE GOT
PEOPLE SPREAD ALL OVER THE
PLACE. DEALING WITH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND HERE'S ONE
THAT'S PROBABLY THE MOST
INFORMED PERSON ON LEGAL ISSUES
AT LAKE TAHOE. AND HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE PREPARED
TO ACT INDEPENDENTLY HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE YOU SET THE OFFICE.
SITUATION THAT YOU GET THAT
INFORMATION AND HOW DO YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE READY TO ACT
INDEPENDENTLY FEW HALF TO I
MEAN. YOU FEEL LIKE ALL THOSE
THINGS ARE TIED TOGETHER IN
THAT. I MEAN YOU YOU POINT TO
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES OF
RUNNING OUT OF AN OFFICE WITH.
AS MANY TALENTED. A PERSONALITY
HOUSES AS A BROADER SCOPE OF
SUBJECT MATTER THAT COVERS AND
AS BIG AS IT IS AND- IT'S YOU
KNOW I HOPE YOU KNOW THIS IS
IDEALISTIC I KNOW BUT I HOPE.
IF I CONFIRMED THAT I'LL BE
ABLE TO MEET. AND SPEND TIME
WITH THE MANY GREAT MEMBERS OF
THE OFFICE INTRODUCED THEM TO
WHO I AM WHAT I CARE ABOUT WHAT
I MY VALUES OR MY VISION IS.
AND I HOPE TO BE ABLE TO. EARN
THEIR TRUST AND GETUS ON THE
SAME PAGE I KNOW THAT'S
DIFFICULT. TOM BUT THAT'S MY
HOPE AND I ALSO KNOW. THAT IT'S
IN THAT YOU CAN WHEN YOU'RE
SEEKING AN OUTCOME AN OUTCOME
THAT'S GOOD FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE AND OPTIMISE GOOD FOR
THE NATURAL RESOURCES OF THE
STATE. AND IT'S DELICATE AND
SENSITIVE SOMETIMES THE RIGHT
PERSONALITIES WORKING WITH THE
OTHER RIGHT PERSONALITIES CAN
CREATE THE MAGIC TO GET THERE.
AND SO HAVING THE RIGHT PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM AT THE RIGHT TIME I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT. BY RELYING ON
ENTRUSTING. THE GREAT TOWN THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS GOING TO
BE IMPORTANT TO BUT IT'S A IT'S
A BALANCING ACT HAVE YOU STATES
MULTI FACTORIAL. AND IT'S NOT
EASY. A THE- CENTER BAY ASKED
ABOUT. CONV WHICH I WANT TALK
AND GRAVE FOR THAT AND MAYBE
ONE LAST THING- I ASKED IN THE
MEETING WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES
WOULD BE. THE FIRST THING THAT
YOU MENTIONED WAS HAVING TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW THAT IS
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT HOW YOU
SEE THAT AND WHAT YOU. THINK
YOU WOULD DO GIVEN THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. ABSOLUTELY. ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
IS GOING TO DO IN THE COMING
WEEKS AND MONTHS IS STANDING UP.
THE OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTING
DIVISION THAT IS CALLED FOR BY
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX. A BILL THAT
MY- COLLEAGUES ARE PROBABLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY
WAS LEAD AUTHOR ON I WAS TRYING
TO PULL OFF THEIR WITH THEM.
MYERS THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
DO A INDEPENDENT OUTSIDE
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION OF. ALL
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS THAT
LEAD TO THE DEATH OF A
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW. AS WE HAVE
A RACIAL JUSTICE RECKONING IN
THIS NATION HOW WE- HAVE A
RECKONING AROUND HOW WE- POLICE
IN THE STATE AND IN THIS NATION
HOW WE THINK ABOUT WHAT I THINK
IS SO NECESSARY THAT WE NEED TO
REBUILD THAT TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES AND
I BELIEVE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE INVALUABLE- PARTS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY WANT TO BUILD INTERNET
TRUST. ACCOUNTABILITY IS PART
OF THAT TRUST AND STANDING UP
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX A KEY PART-
TO TRY TO THE AMERICA YOU ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE.
SUPPORTING AND TRAINING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND HIGHWAYS WHERE
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL. IN
THINGS LIKE COMMUNITY POLICING
AND DE ESCALATION- AND HOW TO
IDENTIFY AND INVESTIGATE HATE
CRIMES AND IN REDUCING AND
REMOVING IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT
BIAS. THEIR- WITH A CONTACT AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX WE EXPECT BASED
ON HISTORICAL DATA THAT THERE
WILL BE ABOUT. FORTY OF THE
CASES THAT QUALIFY UNDER AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO GET IT RIGHT. THE
TWENTY GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS
NOT. IN THE PAST GENERALLY.
INVESTIGATED LARGE NUMBERS OF
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS AND
SO RAMPING UP TO BE ABLE TO DO
FORTY A YEAR. IS AN IMPORTANT
VERY IMPORTANT ENDEAVOR AND-
THOSE WHO ARE GRIEVING THE LOSS
OF LIFE OF FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
DIED DURING INTERACTIONS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. ANYONE WHO IS
BEING INVESTIGATED THE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA. ALL
DESERVE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
THAT'D BE. THOROUGH AND
ACCURATE AND COMPREHENSIVE AND
RELIABLE AND FULL OF INTEGRITY
SO THAT WHEN AN INVESTIGATION
IS COMPLETE. THE RESULTS ARE
TRUSTED FOR THAT'S GOING TO BE
A VERY IMPORTANT. FIRST BY ONE
OF THE FIRST PRIORITIES SHOULD
I HAVE THE HONOR BEING
CONFIRMED. I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I WANT TO LEAVE. QUESTIONS
FOR OTHER PEOPLE BUT A ME OUT
BOB YOU MIGHT HAVE THE SAME
EXPERIENCE I HAD WHEN I WAS IN
THE CABINET WHERE I WOULD BE IN
A MEETING AND SOMEBODY WOULD
SAY WELL WHO AUTHORED THIS
STUPID LAW. AND I WOULD HAVE TO
TELL THEM WHO HAD BEEN INVOLVED
IN THAT. SO I WISH YOU LUCK IN
THE- THANK YOU'VE BEEN REALLY
RISK. TO MARK. THANK YOU CENTER
THERE TO. THANK SENATOR LET ME
TURN TO US SENATOR COM LOCKER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WELL- I
JUST WANNA SAY THAT I'M REALLY
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY WITH YOU
I. WAS THINKING ABOUT OUR WALKS
AND NAV AND THE YOUR THE GARDEN
OUTSIDE THE PARK AND KIND OF
TALKING ABOUT ALL KINDS OF.
WONDERFUL POSSIBLE SCENARIOS
AND SO- TO BE HERE WITH YOU
TODAY IS REALLY HEARTWARMING
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOUR FAMILY
HERE I KNOW YOUR WIFE MIA WAS
HERE A LITTLE EARLIER. AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO KNOW EVEN
THOUGH YOU'RE I WANT TO TELL
YOU THAT EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE
FROM THE BAY AREA- THE FILIPINO
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN LA. IS
POPPING BOTTLES LIKE NOBODY'S
BUSINESS INCREDIBLY EXCITED
ABOUT- THIS MOMENT SO I WANTED
TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU. AND LET
YOU KNOW THAT YOU HAVE LOVE
COMING FROM FROM LA- AND FROM
OUR FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WORLD I JUST
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I KNOW WE
HAD A REALLY FUN- DISCUSSION
EARLIER THIS WEEK. AND I THINK
I MENTIONED THAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK YOU ABOUT. SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THE FIRST ONE. IS- ABOUT
HEALTHCARE. AND SPECIFICALLY
THAT MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS
OF HOSPITALS. A WE KNOW THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL YOU KNOW
FILED AN ANTITRUST LAWSUIT
THERE WAS A SETTLEMENT IN THE
OFFICE OF THE AG FILED IN
OPPOSITION TO THE DELAY OF THE
SETTLEMENT I THINK JUST
RECENTLY. THERE WAS A PARTIAL
SUMMARY JUDGMENT- AND I BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A TRIAL SET FOR
LATER THIS YEAR THIS IS
SPECIFIC TO SUTTER HEALTH BUT-
I KNOW THAT THE STATE IS REALLY
ARGUED THAT- CONSOLIDATION IS
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS. FOR
THE EXPENSIVE COST OF HEALTH-
AND HOW DO WE REALLY MANAGE
THAT AND I BELIEVE THE ARGUMENT
IS THE LARGER THE SHARE OF THE
MARKET THAT A HOSPITAL
CONTROLS. THAT ALSO MEANS ARE
ABLE TO DECIDE DECIDE COST TO
DECIDE CARE EVEN TO DECIDE
LABOR. THERE WAS A GREAT EXPOSE
LATE LAST YEAR THAT ACTUALLY
TALKED ABOUT THE COST OF HAVING
A BABY AND SAID THAT THE COST
OF HAVING A BABY IN SACRAMENTO.
WAS GREATER THAN THE COST OF
HAVING A BABY IN NEW YORK. AND
TAKING CARE OF A PREMATURE BABY
IN NORTHERN CAL IS ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
TAKING CARE FOR PREMATURE BABY
IN SOUTHERN CAL IS ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND-
INCREDIBLY. EXPENSIVE AND- WE
HAVE GOT TO GET A HANDLE ON
THIS- AND ALSO THAT SOME OF
THESE HOSPITALS ARE NOT PAYING.
I THINK LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES OR
EVENBUSINESS TAXES WE KNOW
THAT THE FORMER AG WAS
PARTICULARLY AGGRESSIVE IN THIS
SPACE AND JUST WANTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU- WHERE YOU STAND ON
THIS ISSUE AND WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT FROM YOU. AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. THANK
YOU SENATE ACCOMMODATE ME FOR
SAY THANK YOU FOR REMINDING ME
AND- WHAT I ALREADY KNEW WHICH
WAS THAT THE THAT THE JOY OF
OUR WILL ARE ARE LOCKED
TOGETHER IN A CONVERSATION THAT
WE HAD AND ALSO FOR THE KIND
WORDS THAT YOU SHARED FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU FOR THAT-
HEALTH CARE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
TO ME. IT HAS BEEN SINCE BEFORE
I CAME TO THIS THIS LEGISLATURE
HI HI I FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE
THAT. EVERY PERSON. DESERVES
TRUE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE. AND THAT
WE NEED TO BE ON- THE ON GOING
ON GOING PURSUIT OF THAT
OUTCOME AND TO BE IMPATIENT FOR
CHANGE AND HAVE A SENSE OF
URGENCY- MY FATHER SET UP
HEALTH CARE CLINICS FOR THE
FARMWORKERS. IN CALIFORNIA AND
IN FLORIDA HERE TO WORK FOR
WHAT IS NOW THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH SETTING UP
CLINICS IN RURAL AREAS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MY
FIRST JOB IN PUBLIC SERVICE AS
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL WAS THE
ALAMEDA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
PROVIDING. HEALTH CARE TO. BY
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA I HAVE
SERVED ON THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
SINCE DAY ONE IN THIS-
LEGISLATURE AND HAD THE HONOR
OF SERVING AS CHAIR FOR TIME.
AND ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY IS
CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHAT THE
AG'S ROLE IS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE OVERSIGHT. ROLE ON THE TEN
MERGERS. ENSURING STANDING UP
FOR THE CONSUMER THATPERSON
WHO IS PAYING THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS UP IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- AND MAKING
SURE THAT. THEY DON'T HAVE
HIGHER COSTS WERE LESS ACCESS.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE ONES LOOK
TO YOU KNOW THINK ABOUT THE
EVERYDAY PERSON OUR NEIGHBORS
OUR FRIENDS OR LOVED ONES WHO
NEED HEALTH CARE WHO DON'T WANT
TO HAVE- A HEALTH CARE
PROCEDURE TO MAKE THEM BANKRUPT
YOU DON'T WANT TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THEIR HOSPITAL BILLS
AND THEIR RENT OR THEIR- FOOD
ON THE TABLE. TO ALL BE SEEING
AND THAT'S WILL BE FIGHTING FOR
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU CAN EXPECT
FROM ME SHOULD I HAVE THE HONOR
OF BEING CONFIRMED. THANK YOU
FOR THAT- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING A PARTNER WITH YOU IN
THAT FIGHT. SO I'M NOT LONG AGO
I THINK A FEW YEARS AGO US
SENATOR SKINNER ACTUALLY PASSED
AND GOT SIGNED INTO LAW SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE- WHICH
PERMITS THE INSPECTION OF
CERTAIN PIECE. AND CUSTODY
OFFICER RECORDS. WE KNOW THAT
THAT BECAUSE A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE WERE A NUMBER OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT
COMPLIED WITH THE LAW- HAVING
SAID THAT SOME DESTROYED
RECORDS. BEFOREIT WENT INTO
EFFECT AND SOME INCLUDING THE
DOJ REFUSED TO COMPLY AND
EVENTUALLY THEY DID BUT TO A%
SMALLER DEGREE THEN I THINK
WHAT WAS EXPECTED. SO JUST
WANTED TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU
HOW WILL YOU ENSURE THAT YOUR
OFFICE. COMPLIES WITH RELEASING
REQUESTED RECORDS. BUT I
SUPPORTED THAT BILL. AS A
LEGISLATOR AND I KNOW IT'S.
LETTER AND I KNOW IT'S INTENT.
AND IT IS DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY
TO. PROVIDE FOR INCREASED
DISCLOSURE OUR AND MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND BUT HOPEFULLY
LEAD TO GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND THAT WILL
BE MICHAEL TO DISCLOSE A
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW- I KNOW
THAT THERE WERE SOME CONCERNS-
MAYBE QUESTIONS AND I'M
LEARNING AS I KIND OF GOT MY
REDHOUNDS HEAD AROUND AND
EXECUTIVE FUNCTION EXECUTIVE
FUNCTIONS PUSHED LEGISLATIVE
FUNDS WE PUT BILLS INTO THE
WORLD. AND SOMETIMES THOSE WHO
ARE- ASKED IMPLEMENT THEM THOSE
QUESTIONS ARE THE DEPUTY ORDERS
A SCENARIO WHERE ANTHONY
CLARITY AND THERE WERE SOME
AREAS HERE WHERE. THIRTY HAS
NOT BEEN PROVIDED WITH RESPECT
TO PROSPECTIVE PURSES
RETROSPECTIVE RECORD PRODUCTION.
WITH RESPECT TO- RECORDS BY THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE VERSUS THIRD
PARTY RECORDS IN THE POSSESSION
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE REALLY
GETTING TO A CLEAR PATH NOW
THAT WILL ALLOW FOR WHAT I WANT
WHAT THE BILL IS INTENDED TO
DO. WHICH IS TO DISCLOSE
CONSISTENT WITHOUT LOCK. I LOVE
THAT BECAUSE SO OFTEN YOU HEAR
FOLKS SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
INTENT OF THE AUTHOR WAS AND
YOU CAN SAY WELL. TELL YOU. I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU- SO MY LAST
QUESTION IS. I THINK DISTRICT
OR REGION SPECIFIC IT'S ABOUT
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I KNOW
WE DID TALK ABOUT THIS. IN OUR
MEETING TOGETHER- THE FORMER AG
LAUNCHED A CIVIL RIGHTS
INVESTIGATION OF OUR- L. A.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR. I DO KNOW
THAT THE INVESTIGATION IS
ONGOING AND THERE'S PROBABLY
LITTLE THAT YOU CAN SAY ABOUT
THE INVESTIGATION BUT- I'M
CURIOUS. TO KNOW WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT FROM YOU. YOU KNOW ON
THIS BECAUSE THE INVESTIGATION
COMES AFTER ALLEGATIONS OF
EXCESSIVE FORCE RETALIATION.
AND OTHER MISCONDUCT- AS WELL
AS SOME RECENT REPORTED
INCIDENTS WERE OF ALL
INVOLVING. LASD MANAGEMENT AND
PERSONNEL. AND SO IF YOU CAN
SHARE ANYTHING ON THE STATUS OF
THE INVESTIGATION THAT WOULD BE
GREAT- AND IF YOU CANNOT WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR FROM YOU WHAT KIND
OF. OVERSIGHT OPTIONS THAT YOU
ARE WILLING TO EXPLORE ONCE
THIS INVESTIGATION CONCLUDES
BECAUSE THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR SO MANY
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT.
BUT ALSO FOR SO MANY FOLKS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THERE IS AS WE ALL
KNOW A CURRENT INVESTIGATION BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
INTO THE ALLEY- COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE- I HOPE IF I
AM CONFIRMED TO GET FULLY
BRIEFED ON IT STATUS IT AS YOU
SAY IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE TO
COMMENT ON ANY DETAILS OF THE
OF THE CURRENT INVESTIGATION
I'M FRANKLY NOT PRIVY TO THEM
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT AT THE
MOMENT- BUT I'M AWARE OF ITS
EXISTENCE AND I THINK- I'M-
I'M- MY PLAN IS TO SEE IT
THROUGH. NOW TO GET FULLY
BRIEFED ON IT. AND TO USE THE
TOOLS OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
TOOLBOX TO HELP- GET TO
MEANINGFUL THOUGHTFUL- DURABLE
REFORM. WHERE THERE ARE
VIOLATIONS OF CIVIL RIGHTS TO
CREATE BETTER M. PRACTICES AND
PATTERNS USING THAT THE TOOLS
GIVEN BY THE LEGISLATURE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
BRING PATTERN AND PRACTICE
CASES- SOMETIMES THEY CAN BE
COLLABORATIVE SOMETIMES THEIR
THEIR SUIT. OFTEN THEY LEAD TO
CONSENT JUDGMENTS ARE
STIPULATED JUDGMENTS THAT
CREATE A BETTER PATHWAY FORWARD
TO END SOME OF THE VIOLATIONS
WE SAW IN THE PAST AND HAVE A-
A BETTER. MORE JUST BETTER
PRACTICES THAT ARE MORE YOU
KNOW THAT CONSISTS OF A CIVIL
RIGHTS SO I SEE THAT AS A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE OF THE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE AND I
ATTENDED A FULLY BRIEFED ON THE
SPECIFIC INVESTIGATION AND TAKE
ACTION CONSISTENT WITH THE
VALUES I JUST SHOWED. THANK YOU
WELL IF YOU FIND THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT SIZED
SCREWDRIVER OR WRENCH- OR IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH BOLTS I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL CALL US SO
THAT WE CAN HELP YOU GET THOSE
TOOLS. AND I AM VERY EXCITED
FOR YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR WHILE
WE WITH A- THE OPPORTUNITY
WHILE WE HAVE SENATOR GROWTH
HERE BECAUSE SHE IS DOING
DOUBLE DUTY WITH- HEALTH
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY CAN I
ASK YOU TO GO BACK AND OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE BILL REFERRALS- SO
WE CAN GET THAT VOTE RECORDED.
GROWTH IDROVE FIVE. FIVE TO
ZERO THANK YOU FIVE ZERO AND
NOT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME DO THAT. LET ME
ASK ARE YOU READY TO GO OR
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GO FIRST.
I CAN GO TO THAT EMAIL
ABSOLUTELY I WANNA I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE'VE I WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'VE GOT YOU COVERED FOR. THE
DOUBLE DUTY YOU'RE DOING TODAY
SO SENATOR GO RIGHT AHEAD THINK
HE'S MAD PRETEND YOU'RE ALWAYS
SO GRACIOUS AND HELP ME WITH
THIS DOUBLE DUTY COMMITTEE AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR I DON'T
KNOW I THINK I KEPT YOU ON THE
PHONE FOR OVER AN HOUR. THE
OTHER DAY AN HOUR AND A HALF
ANSWERING EVERY QUESTION THAT I
HAD AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
AND- YOUR FORTHCOMING. NESS
THAT YOU PROVIDED TO ME S. AND
WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
YOU BEING THE FIRST FILIPINO
AMERICAN EVER APPOINTED TO THIS
POSITION AND WHAT IT MEANT TO
YOUR MOM AND I'M I APOLOGIZE
I'M AND DOUBLE DUTY WITH HEALTH
AND I'M ASSUMING THAT'S YOUR
MOM. IN THE FRONT ROW.
CONGRATULATIONS MA'AM. BY WE
DID SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF TIME HIGH ON SEVERAL ISSUES
I'M ONE OF THEM OBVIOUSLY IS
THAT THE SECOND AMENDMENT WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT IS THEM. NEAR
AND DEAR NOT ONLY TO ME BUT TO
MY- COMMUNITY AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE TALK
SIGNIFICANTLY ABOUT- YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY YOU KNOW
PREVENT LAW BREAKERS FROM
OBTAINING FIREARMS ARE HAVING
FIREARMS. WELL ALLOWING EVERY
DAY NINE AM CITIZENS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THEIR RIGHT BE
PROTECTED UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION. AFTER UNTIL LIKE
AND IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE FEWER CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
AND- COMPARED TO OTHER STATES
AND WE'RE NOT THE WORST BUT
WE'RE DEFINITELY NOT EVEN IN
THE TOP FIFTY PERCENT- THAT
WE'RE NOT IN THE TOP 50% AND
I'VE BEEN LOOKING THROUGH A LOT
OF YOUR LEGISLATION THAT YOU'VE
SUPPORTED IN THE PAST AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND SOME OF
THE LEGISLATION THAT YOU'VE
ACTUALLY VOTED ON THAT WAS
VETOED BY THE CURRENT GOVERNOR
IN OUR PREVIOUS GOVERNOR WITH
BILLS THAT YOU SUPPORTED- AS-
IT DID NOT REALLY LINE UP WITH
WHAT WE HAD. CTUALLY TALKED
ABOUT SOMEONE TO GO OVER A
COUPLE OF THINGS WHAT'S YOUR
POSITION ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS ACTUALLY HAVING THE
ABILITY TO HAVE FIREARMS TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES OR- JUST
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT. MY VIEW
IS THAT. BY ANOTHER SEGMENT I
RESPECT THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
ANYONE WHO. I CONSIST OF THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IS A LAW
ABIDING GUN OWNER FOR SELF
DEFENSE OR FOR HUNTING OR FOR
SPORTING OR WHATEVER THE
REASON. I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
A QUARREL WITH I DO HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH MASS SHOOTINGS
PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED- TO
REGULARLY ASSEMBLY THAT CANNOT
BECOME NORMAL- BUT SADLY HAD
THREATENED TO BECOME NORMAL- I
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH NEW TOWN. I
HAVE PROBLEMS WITH KIDS BEING
SHOT EN MASSE IN SCHOOL I HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH CHILDREN HAVING
TO DO ACTIVE GUN SHOOTER DRILLS
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE AS LEADERS C. THAT AS THE
PROBLEM THAT IT IS. AND TAKE
COMMONSENSE STEPS WITHIN THE
BOUNDS OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AND
PROTECT CHILDREN IN FAMILIES
AND CALIFORNIANS. AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THAT AND I TO HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THOSE SHOOTINGS IN THE
ISSUES THAT COME UP. WITH AS
THE TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON THE
BOOKS OR WHAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEE. THAT WOULD PREVENT THAT
FROM HAPPENING. I THINK WE-
HAVE HAD SOME REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT- A BI
PARTISAN EFFORT TO. REMOVE GUNS
FROM THOSE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE
IT BASED ON THE LAW AND THAT
IS- IMPLEMENTATIONOF ON
PREPARE PERSON SYSTEM DATABASE
AND WE KNOW THAT THE- THE
NUMBER OF. ACTIVE CASES ARE ALL
INDIVIDUALS I SHOULDN'T HAVE
GUNS AND THAT WE SHOULD WORK
TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO- REDUCE
THAT I IDENTIFIED EARLIER FOR
SENATOR BATES WHO WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN THIS THIS POLICY
AREA A COUPLE OF CHALLENGES. I
THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS AND WE NEED TO OVERCOME TO
BEAT THE IMPLEMENTOR OF THE
APP'S DATABASE- THAT THE DRIVEN
GOVERNMENT WILL THAT WE WANT TO
BE- AND THAT COULD BE SOME
POLICY- IN WETHERBY BUDGET- OR
OR OTHER TYPE OF POLICY TO HELP
US GET THE RIGHT PERSON NOW THE
SPECIAL AGENTS. WORK WOULD HAVE
TO MANY VACANCIES RIGHT NOW TO
BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT AND GET ON
ON THE GROUND AND REMOVE THE
GUNS FROM THOSE SHOULDN'T HAVE
IT. IT COULD ALSO BE
LEGISLATION OR YOU KNOW YOU'VE
POTENTIALLY BUDGET LEGISLATION
TO HELP ASSIST WITH THE NEED
FOR A BETTER TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL PLATFORM THAT'S A
LITTLE MORE FLUID IN A LITTLE
MORE HELPFUL. IN HELPING
IDENTIFY QUICKLY- THOSE WHO
HAVE NEED HAVE COUNTRY MOVE SO
THAT THAT'S ONE AREA AND LOOK
AT THEM I'M REALLY INTERESTED
AND EXCITED FOR THE POSSIBILITY
OF BIPARTISAN WORK SOME OF THE
TWO OF THE BIGGEST THINGS I
EVER DID IN THE LEGISLATURE
WERE FOUND IN COLLABORATION
WITH BIPARTISAN. GROUPS ONE WAY
TO SUPPORTING REGULATIONS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND CHILDREN AND
THE ENVIRONMENT AROUND MEDICAL
CANNABIS PROMISE OF AN OVERLAP
HE WAS A KEY PART OF THAT GROUP
ANOTHER WAS A CRITICAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION. EFFORTS TO BAN THE
USE OF SURPRISE MEDICAL BILLS.
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER STALI AND
MAIENSCHEIN AS PART OF THE
GROUP AS WELL WE CAN DO BIG
THINGS TOGETHER BIPARTISAN. IF
WE SEEK AND FIND COMMON GROUND.
THANK YOU AM I DO PRE THAT I
APPRECIATE RESPOND. WAS LOOKING-
LITTLE BIT MORE IF AND YOU WANT
TO CONTACT ME AFTERWARDS THAT'S
FINE TOO- I WAS LOOKING FOR A
LITTLE BIT MORE YOU KNOW I SEE
THE GUN LAWS TO GO THROUGH THIS
BUILDING FIREARM LAWS TO GO
THROUGH THIS BUILDING. AND I
DON'T SEE A LOT THAT STOPS- YOU
KNOW FOR INSTANCE THREE
SHOOTINGS THE BOOK THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTING DOWN AT
TIME VENTURA. THAT WASN'T A
PROHIBITED PERSON THAT YOU KNOW
SO- THAT WAS INTERPRETED A
PERSON SO I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
WE DO NEED TO GO AFTER THIS YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS THERE
ARE PROHIBITED PERSONS ON THAT
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST THAT
SHE AND I KNOW SENATOR BATES
PROBABLY COVERED THAT
EXTENSIVELY. THERE HAS TO BE
SOLUTIONS- THAT DON'T AFFECT-
IN THE SAME SENSE THAT THE
GENTLEMAN WHO COMMITTED THE
BORDERLINE MASSACRE WHICH SAW
THE LARGEST ONES WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA. WAS NOT A
PROHIBITED PERSON. AND IS THE
SAME WAY THAT THE ILLEGAL
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT THAT WAS
DRIVING ON A CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY. THAT WAS IN A STOLEN
VEHICLE THAT DIDN'T HAVE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE I MEAN EVERY
THING YOU COULD THINK OF
BREAKING THE LAW. AND HE CAME
ACROSS A- SEEK. A POLICE
OFFICER OFFICER SCENE. AND SHOT
HIM WE ALL WENT REMEMBER THAT
RE FUNERAL IT WAS HORRIFIC.
THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME TYPE OF
BALANCE BECAUSE- BUY BACK
PROGRAMS THINGS LIKE THAT. AND
NOEL. NO PERSON LIKE THAT
INDIVIDUAL DRIVING THAT
VEHICLE. ILLEGALLY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE ILLEGAL
FIREARM BREAKING THE LAW. FROM
EIGHT IZZY. IS GOING TO TURN IN
A FIREARM. AND THEY PRAYED
SCRATCH THE SERIAL NUMBER OF
THE FIREARMS YOU KNOW. THEY
PROBABLY FOUND ANOTHER WAY
BESIDES REGISTERING REMISSION
IN ORDER TO PURCHASE AMMUNITION
I DON'T THINK THEY WENT AND GOT
IT. DOJ CLEARANCE TO PURCHASE
AMMUNITION. SO ALL OF THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT YOU READ THAT
THAT THE LAWS REQUIRE FOR LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS LIKE ME HAVE
CARRIED A FIREARM SINCE I LEFT
THE MILITARY I'VE HAD ONE. YOU
KNOW FOR THEM SINCE I LEFT THE
MILITARY. AND MY FAMILY GREW UP
FIRE DISCRIMINATE RANCH SO
WITH. YOU KNOW WE ALL LEARNED
HOW TO SHOOT WE WERE LITTLE
KIDS. AND SO ALL OF THE LAWS
THAT ARE PUT IN PLACE AND YOU
BEING THE TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE JUST GONNA
HURT OR RESTRICT LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS. BUT THOSE THAT- YOU
KNOW LIKE JUST FOR EXAMPLE AND
I DON'T MEAN TO KEEP BELIEVING
THE ISSUE WILL MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING ELSE- WE NOW HAVE TO
CHECK WE PURCHASED A MUNITION
FOR THE DOJ YET FELT THIS PIECE
OF PAPER. YOU HAVE TO ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS WHEN YOU'RE
THERE TO PURCHASE AMMUNITION
AND IN THE SENATE BACK SAYING
YES YOU'RE OKAY OR NO YOU'RE
NOT OKAY. AND WE'RE GOING TO
PURCHASE OUR AMMUNITION
LAWFULLY BUT THE CRIMINALS
THEY'RE NOT DALY TO RELOAD
THEY'LL FIND SOME WAY TO GET
THEIR AMMUNITION. SO I JUST I'M
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING SOME TYPE
OF ANY COULD BE VAGUE IF YOU
WANT TO BE VAGUE BUT I'M
LOOKING FOR SOME TYPE OF
COMMITMENT THAT. WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON ISSUES THAT STOP
CRIMINALS. FROM OBTAINING
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT WITH AN INTENT
TO HURT PEOPLE AND LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS THEY JUST WANT THEIR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS-
PROTECTED. DON'T HAVE TO GO
THROUGH HOOP AFTER HOOP AFTER
HOOP AFTER HOOP. TO BUY A BOX
OF FIFTY ROUNDS. YOU KNOW NINE
MILLIMETER. YOU KNOW IT IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT SENATOR BY I
APPRECIATE IT- AND JUST TO BE
CLEAR I WAS NOT SUGGESTING THAT
THE APPS. SYSTEM IS A PNACEA A
CURE ALL FOR ALL THINGS
CONFINEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA. HI
I WAS JUST POINTING IT OUT AS A
AN AREA BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT
GENERALLY I THINK. AND A PLACE
WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS AND WORK
TOGETHER SINCE YOU ASKED FOR AN
EXAMPLE- I DO REALIZE THERE ARE
OTHER TOOLS THAT NEED TO BE
USED TO. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OTHER SCENARIOS THAT YOU
MENTIONED WHERE APPS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ADEQUATE OR
SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE- I ALSO REALIZE THERE
ARE- THAT YOU INDICATE FOLKS
WHO- ENOUGH FOR THE LAWS. AND
WILL WILL ACQUIRE GUNS AND
AMMUNITION. OUTSIDE OF LAW. SO
YOU KNOW TO ME THAT MEANS IT'S
IMPORTANT- IT'S SET TO THINK
THROUGH WHO AND HOW. AND WHERE.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERDICTION. TO HELP ADDRESS
AND BREAK UP THOSE. SORT OF
SUPPLY LINES. I COULD BE
HELPFUL- AT THE MULTIPLE. WAYS
TO DO THIS AND YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE ONE THING I APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
CARES DEEPLY ABOUT THIS ISSUE
FOUR- SENATOR BATES. AND YOU
HAVE BOTH SAID WHEN I TALKED
ABOUT WHY I CARE ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE YOU TOLD ME YOU AGREE.
THAT THAT THOSE MASSACRES ARE
NOT ACCEPTABLE THAT YOU WANT
AND THEN TO. WHERE WE DON'T
ALWAYS AGREES ON THE HALF- BUT
I AM WILLING TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU I DO SEE
YOUR POINTS. ABOUT OTHER PLACES
OUTSIDE OF SOMEBODY APPROACHES
THAT I MAY HAVE. BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR THE PAST DECADE
ALSO WERE YOU COULD ALSO MAKE
PROGRESS. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE BENEFIT OF COOPERATION AND
DIALOGUE AND DISCUSSION. TO
FIND OTHER PATHWAYS WE CAN MAKE
PROGRESS. AND SOME YOU KNOW
MAYBE WANT TO GREET ME AND-
LIKE. I GENERALLY THINK. M. IF
IT'S A- REASONABLE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THANK
THAT INVOLVES- YOU KNOW
BACKGROUND CHECK OR SOME
REGISTRATION- AND NOT COULD
LEAVE. LEAD TO SAVING SOMEONE'S
LIFE. CAN THE- INCONVENIENT.
MAYBE VERY INCONVENIENT- IT'S
SOMETHING WE REALLY NEED TO
CONSIDER. BECAUSE IT'S A IT'S A
LIFE SAVED MAYBE MULTIPLE LIVES
SAVED. SO I DON'T I DON'T TAKE
IT LIGHTLY. BUT I THINK ON
BALANCE IF YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE
A LIFE FOR. YOU KNOW WITH THE
FOR A LITTLE MORE RIGHT
REGULATION A LITTLE
REGISTRATION. OF MORE MINUTES
AT ADMINISTRATIVE OVERSIGHT. IT
IT'S WORTH IT. I DISAGREE AND I
WOULD PINE ARE NOT RESPECT THAT
THAT THAT THAT DISAGREEMENT IN
YOUR OPINION. I'M NOT I DON'T I
DON'T NEED TO GET IT. FRANKLY I
REALLY DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU
I DON'T MIND GOING IN A
RESTAURANT I DON'T MIND GOING
TO A TRAINING CLASS TO MAKE
SURE I'M STILL ADEQUATE
QUALIFIED USED BY FIREARMS. I
DON'T MIND AND- SPENDING THE
TIME FOR PRACTICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF SOMETHING EVER DID
HAPPEN IT NEVER HAS AND YOU
KNOW THE ENTIRE TIME THAT I'VE
HAD A FIREARM. BUT IF SOMETHING
DID HAPPEN THAT YOU KNOW DE I
WOULD BE DEAD THE BEST
QUALIFIED BEST TRAINED BEST YOU
KNOW OF IT NOT TO HARM ANYBODY
OTHER THAN THE PERPETRATOR THAT
WAS HURTING ME OR- MY FAMILY.
OR SOMEONE ELSE THANK GOD I'VE
NEVER BEEN IN THAT POSITION. SO
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH YOU ON THAT. I THINK WHAT
WE DO. WE DISAGREE IS THAT.
WHILE I DON'T MIND DOING THAT
AND I KNOW. SEVERAL OF MY
FRIENDS THAT HAVE FIREARMS.
THEY DON'T IND DOING THAT THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PERSON. THAT IS BREAKING THE
LAW CONTINUALLY. HAS IS THERE
IS WE STOP THE WAY THAT THEY
GET THEIR FIREARMS SO THAT THEY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE SAME
PROCESS SO. YOU IN YOUR NEW JOB
CAN SAY NOW. AND IF YOU KNOW
THERE THAT TAKE THAT PERSON. I
APPRECIATE THAT I DON'T I'M
GONNA ASK A QUESTION BECAUSE I
WAS GONE. AND I WAS IN HEALTH
DID AND SENATOR BATES- DID YOU.
ASK THE POTENTIAL THE NOMINEE
ABOUT SENATORS DALIBOR JUST
MCGUIRE INTO ILLEGAL POT GROWS
YOU DID NOT OKAY SO I'M GONNA
GO TO THAT SUBJECT MATTER IF
THAT'S OKAY I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU HADN'T ALREADY
ANSWERED THOSE QUESTIONS AND
BE. DUPLICATIVE SO A PARTICULAR
INTEREST OF MYSELF SENATOR
DOLLY A FLORIDA MCGUIRE AND
SENATOR BORDERS ON THE ILLEGAL
POT GROWS ON THE STATE LANDS.
AND THE IMPACT OUR WATER THE
YOU KNOW THAT MY FAMILY RANCH
THERE'S ILLEGAL POT GROW THE
SHERIFF CAME. THERE WAS AND
CANS OF CHEMICALS. BERYL'S BIG
BARRELS OF CHEMICALS TRASH
EVERYTHING. EXTRA WATER STREET.
AND AGAIN. AND THIS IS NOT IN
YOUR PURVIEW PER SE BUT SO THE
RANCHESTER REPORT EVERY DROP OF
WATER THAT'S AWFUL WATERSHED
EVERY DROP OF WATER THAT COMES
OUT OF A PIPE. BUT YET THESE
PEOPLE CAN DESTROY OUR WATER ON
OUR LAND AND WE THERE'S NO
THERE'S NOTHING THERE SO
THERE'S IT'S NOT THE SAME
EQUITY IN THE LAWS. AND AS
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
INCREDIBLE ENVIRONMENTAL
CLIMATE- DAMAGE FROM THESE
ILLEGAL MARIJUANA GROWS. WHAT'S
YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS ON A
DRESSING THESE ILLEGAL GROWS ON
STATE LANDS AND PRIVATE LANDS
THAT ARE- AFFECTING OUR WATER.
I BELIEVE AND HOPE THAT MY
RECORDS BEEN CLEAR ON THIS THAT.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY
IS IN THE REGULATED MARKET
PLACE THE LEGAL MARKET PLACE
NOT IN THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE
RIGHT NOW WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT
I REALIZE THAT I PAVE I'VE
HEARD FROM SOME NUMBER LACKEY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY ABOUT THE
BILLY DEEP CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE BUT I THINK THIS IS AN
AREA OF AGAIN OF BIPARTISAN
CONCERN AND POTENTIAL
BIPARTISAN SOLUTION- WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT. IT'S NOT OKAY FROM
IT UNDERMINES THE- OPERATORS IN
THE REGULATED MARKET PLACE FOR
FOLLOWING ALL THE RULES PAYING
THEIR TAXES STRUGGLING AS
BUSINESSES TO SUCCEED AND
THEY'RE GETTING UNDER CUT BY
THOSE ILLICIT MARKETPLACES WHO
ARE WHO ARE FLOUTING THE LAW.
WHAT WE DO TO- TO ADDRESS THAT-
THERE MIGHT BE SOME DIFFERENCES
OF OPINION. I DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO A WAR ON DRUGS- I DON'T
WANT TO BE- THAT GO TOO FAR
WITH. IT WITH OVER
CRIMINALIZATION BUT I DO WANT
THE OPERATORS TO NOT BE
OPERATING IN THE ILLICIT MARKET
PLACE AND TO BE OPERATING IN
THE REGULAR MARKET PLACE. SO I
THINK SOME DISCOUNT WE CAN HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW TO GET
THERE. BUT I RECOGNIZE THE
PROBLEM IT IS A PROBLEM FOR ME
AND IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
THANK YOU SIR. AT THE LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS RINGING PAGO
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT
AND BEFORE. THE LAW WAS PASSED
I BELIEVE IN GRAY DAVIS WAS IN
OFFICE- CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS
AGAINST EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WERE ACTUALLY.
DONE BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IF
YOU HAD A SERIOUS ENOUGH
VIOLATION THAT. YOU KNOW
WARRANTED A CLASS ACTION
LAWSUIT IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO TAKE ACTION AND THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT PAGA HAS-
PASSED AND IT'S BECOME LAW.
IT'S CREATED A- DISADVANTAGE TO
A LOT OF- I WOULD SAY HONEST.
EVERYDAY EMPLOYERS IN EMPLOYERS
AREN'T PERFECT I DO NOT
ANY EMPLOYER WHO STEALS WAGES
DOESN'T TREAT THEIR EMPLOYEES
RIGHT DOESN'T PAY THEIR WAGES
CORRECTLY DOESN'T GIVE THE
VACATION BENEFITS THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS. I AM I'M NOT
ADVOCATING FOR THAT AT ALL. BUT
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WAY PAGA HAS AFFECTED
BUSINESSES. FOR INSTANCE- AND-
BUSINESSES AS THEY SAY THEY PAY
WEEKLY EVERY WEEK AND ON THEIR
PAYCHECK STUB IT USED TO SAY.
WE CAN'T IN SEVEN ONE WEEK
ENDING SEVEN EIGHT SO THE
EMPLOYEE KNEW WHAT WEEK THAT
PAY PERIOD COVERED. WELL THE
LAW UNDER LABOR CODE SECTION
TWO TO SIX WHICH MOST PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW. AND SAYS THAT YOU
HAVE TO HAVE INCLUSIVE DATES.
AND IT HAS TO HAVE. A DASH
BETWEEN THE INTO COLUSA DATES.
SO THAT PARTICULAR EMPLOYER WAS
FINED OVER MILLION DOLLARS FOR
NOT HAVING INCLUSIVE DATES
SEVEN ONE TWO SEVEN EIGHT. YOU
KNOWA MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRINTED THING IN A PAYCHECK
STUB. AS THE AFTER YEARS OF
FIGHTING FOR EMPLOYERS ON PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE DID. PASS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON THEM.
AT AT WAY STATEMENTS AS I GUESS
I WAS WHAT I CALL IT AND NOW
THE SOLUTION IS TO REPRINT ALL
THOSE STATEMENTS FEDEX THEM
OVERNIGHT TO EVERY EMPLOYEE HE
WAS AFFECTED WITH THE CORRECT
INFORMATION ON HIM I JUST SAY
ALL THAT BECAUSE PAGO LAWS ARE
I AM VERY DETRIMENTAL TO A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EMPLOYERS
ESPECIALLY EMPLOYERS- BECAUSE
THE VOLUME THAT ATTORNEYS GET-
TUNER FIFTY DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION PER PENALTY AND THERE
COULD BE FOUR FIVE VIOLATIONS
ON ONE PAYCHECK STUB. NOT
HORRENDOUS NOT LIKE BY PAGE YOU
WERE SOMEBODY GOT PAID FORTY
HOURS THEY WORK FORTY HOURS AND
YOU ONLY PAY THEM FOR TWENTY
FIVE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE DASH BETWEEN
THE DATES I'M TALKING ABOUT
APPEAL BOX VERSUS A PHYSICAL
ADDRESS AND BASICALLY THAT
PENALTY APPLIES TO- AND I
REALIZE YOU CAN'T CHANGE
LEGISLATION IN THIS POSITION.
BUT THAT THAT PENALTY APPLIES
TO. AND WE ALL WORK HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE COME TO
WORK AT THIS BUILDING EVERY DAY
IF SOMEBODY SAYS WHO DO YOU
WORK FOR WE COULD SAY THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE SAME THING WITH
CHICORY ACROSS THE STREET OR
ANY OTHER BUSINESS RIGHT
DOESN'T MATTER DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE YOU GO TO WORK. IS
THE PAYCHECKS THAT HAD A PO BOX
ADDRESS ON INSTEAD OF A
PHYSICAL ADDRESS. THE INTENT
INTERPRETATION UNDER THE
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT.
FROM THE PREVIOUS ATTORNEY
GENERAL. IS IT THAT IS
INACCURATE INFORMATION BECAUSE
THE EMPLOYEE DOES NOT HAVE THE
ACCURATE ADDRESS IN WHICH THEY
DO THEIR WORK. WELL THIS IS A
LOT FOR ANY OF OUR EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE WE'LL KNOW WHERE WE
WORK AND WE CAN SAY WE WERE CUT
SACRAMENTO STATE CAPITOL
WHATEVER STAND THAT- YOU COULD
PHYSICALLY REPORT TO TWENTY TWO
WHATEVER TEN FIFTEEN L. STREET
BUT IT MIGHT SAY I THINK WE CAN
GET A CHECK FOR RULE SO WE SKIP
US BECAUSE WE'RE PROBABLY IN
VIOLATION OF THE WHOLE THING
ANYWAYS. AND I JUST WAS CURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT. YOU THOUGHT ABOUT
THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ACT AND HOW ADVERSELY AND AGAIN
I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR THOSE
EMPLOYERS THAT BREAK THE LAW.
AND DON'T PAY WAGES AND
UNDERCUT WAGES TO EMPLOYEES. IN
ADVOCATING FOR THE- OR A
MASKING THE QUESTION ON BEHALF
OF EMPLOYERS AROUND THE STATE
WHERE POGBA HAS GOT A 9100%
INCREASE BECAUSE A LAWS PASSED
IN THIS BUILDING THAT ADVERSELY
AFFECT. NOT ONLY EMPLOYER BUT
NOW THE EMPLOYEES. WHO NO
LONGER GET. COMPANY VEHICLES TO
DRIVE HOME BECAUSE- SOMEBODY
SAID DRIVING HOME WAS A WAGING
OUR ISSUE. WHEN IT ISN'T. SO
NOW THEY DRIVE THEIR OWN CAR.
TO THE JOB SITE BECAUSE THE
COMPANY TRACK CAN DRIVE BACK TO
ANOTHER LOCATION. M. THAT PUTS
MORE VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
THINGS LIKE THAT- I'M
ADVOCATING FOR JUST THE AVERAGE
EVERYDAY EMPLOYERS TRYING TO
SURVIVE THESE LAWS WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHT PROCESS AND I HOPE IT'S
NOT LIKE YOUR PREDECESSOR I'M
NOT TRYING TO PUT YOU IN A
POLITICAL POSITION I'M JUST
LIKE I HOPE IT'S NOT LIKE YOUR
PREDECESSOR- BY. WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT WITH BIPARTISAN THAT
ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I VALUE- THE WORK
THEY DO THE JOB THEY CREATE THE
TAXES THEY PAY FOR THE COMMON
GOOD ACTORS I THINK THAT'S
SHARED ACROSS THE AISLE AND I
ALSO SEE VERY SUPPORT OF OUR
WORKERS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO WORK IN AND FAIR
AND SAFE AND DIGNIFIED AND
RESPECTFUL WORKING CONDITIONS.
AND NOTHING MAKES ME HOW THAN A
VIBRANT- STRONG RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
WHERE. THEY WERE THEY'RE
WORKING TOGETHER- WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT PAGA- AND
BEFORE I TALK TO SENATOR BATES
I WAS ABLE TO DO A LITTLE
RESEARCH TO BECAUSE OF YOUR
INTEREST AND PASSION FOR SENATE
DEBATES BUT I DID HAVE A CHANCE
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT- YOU
KNOW. ADJUSTED JUSTICE DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE. ZORK THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
UNDER STATUTE AND THEY HAVE
DOES- RELEGATED SOME OF THEIR
AUTHORITY TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER- SO A PAGA SUIT IS
BROUGHT THAT THERE IS
GOVERNMENT INTERACTION THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER. DETERMINES
THAT DOESN'T NOTICE LETTER AND
LABOR COMMISSIONER CAN TAKE ON-
A ROLE FOR INVESTIGATION IF
THEY WISH. IF THEY WISH NOT TO
THEN THE PRIVATE. ATTORNEY
GENERAL CAN DO IT AND IT IS A
SETTLEMENT BEING SOUGHT THAT
SETTLEMENT NEEDS TO BE
APPROVED. BUT SO THERE THERE
ARE I GUESS CHECKS AND BALANCES
IN PAPA- THAT I'VE- YOU KNOW
THAT I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU I
KNOW YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
WORKING ON THE GROUND. SO LET
ME JUST AND WITH THIS THE IT'S
AN AREA THAT I WOULD. WANT TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT SPEAK WITH YOU
MORE ABOUT. SPEAK WITH FOLKS IN
THE PARTNER JUSTICE ABOUT. AND
POTENTIALLY THERE IS A WAY TO
BE AWARE WORK TOGETHER TECH TO
GET TO A PLACE WHERE- YOU KNOW
IT CAN WORK FOR ALL.
STAKEHOLDER THANK YOU KNOW I
PRETTY YOU AND- I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR. ME ASK THESE- IN. AND
YOU ALREADY. ALL OF THEM- WITH
THE OUR AND A HALF THAT WE
SPENT ON THE PHONE AND- MA'AM
CAN GRADUALLY. IMAGE ANDA IT IS
SO I WOULD YOU ALL THE BEST.
THANK YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU
SENATOR- AND I APPRECIATE ALL
THE OF MY COLLEAGUES. LET ME
JUST SAY- I ALSO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE OUR WORK
TOGETHER AS COLLEAGUES IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND CERTAINLY WHEN I
WAS SPEAKER AND HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPOINT YOU TO
BE THE CHAIR OF HEALTH AND YOUR
WORK THERE WAS- IT WAS
INCREDIBLE. A COMPLEX ISSUE AT
A COMPLEX TIME AS WE WERE
IMPLEMENTING THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR ROLE ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE OF THE BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR. AND THE WORK
THAT REALLY ADVANCED US SOME OF
THE POLICY ISSUES WE SEE TODAY
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
SAY THANK YOU FOR THAT. YOUR
REPUTATION OF COLLEGIALITY AND
THOUGHTFULNESS IS- SOMETHING
THAT REALLY PROCEED YOU. AND SO
I WANT TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS
AND AS WELL ON THE APPOINTMENT
OF BY OUR GOVERNOR- BECAUSE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY DONE
THIS I HAVE TO SAY THAT WHILE
CA DIEGO MAY HAVE A SMALLER.
API COMMUNITY WE HAVE A AN
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE AND VIBRANT
COMMUNITY SO I'M GONNA ON
BEHALF OF MY OWN COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
BUT SINCE MY COLLEAGUES OPEN
THAT DOOR I FELT LIKE I HAD TO
CHIME RIGHT ON IN ON THAT ONE-
IT'S ALWAYS A WONDERFUL THING
WHEN YOU GET TO SEE SUCCESS. OF
AN INTO. BUT ONE IN WHICH YOU
AS I CAN'T REMEMBER IF IT WAS
A- SENATOR BATES EARLIER WHO
SAID YOU BEAR THE- OF THE
COMMUNITY MORE SO. ARE BECAUSE
OF THAT. WE HAD A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND CONVERSATION
ABOUT A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
ISSUES. AND I THINK EACH OF US
HAVE PULLED OUT OF. THINGS THAT
WE FELT LIKE NEEDED TO BE ON
THE PUBLIC RECORD FOR VARIOUS
REASONS FOR OUR COLLEAGUES OR-
I ONLY HAVE TWO. AND HOPEFULLY
MY- I KNOW THAT MY STAFF GOT
THIS OVER TO YOU TODAY I HAD. A
ZOOM MEETING THIS MORNING WITH
A WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
CONVERSATION AROUND- THE FACT
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS BEEN ASKED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION. TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE ASSOCIATIONS
MISAPPROPRIATION OF MORE THAN
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS REVEALED
BY AN AUDIT. OF INTERNAL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES. WHICH
SHOWED ON AUTHORIZED
EXPENDITURES FOR FUNDS THAT
WERE SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
SAFETY TRAINING PROGRAM
SOMETHING I KNOW. A NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEARTS. SO I'D LOVE
TO ASK YOU TO SHARE WITH US HOW
YOU PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
WITH APPOINTED. CONSIDERING
YOUR OWN DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE
BEEN DIRECTLY IMPACTED. BY THAT
MISAPPROPRIATION. SACRAMENTO
TEM IMAGES FOR SAFE IT WAS AN
TO SERVE AND LEAD WITH YOU AS
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR GIVE ME
HONOR SIR HEALTH COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND OF BOYS AMOUNT OF CALL- I
WAS A SINCE. AS PER CHAIR FOR
WHAT I HAVE THEIR AS HEALTH
CHAIR- AND PRODUCE IT ALL- WITH
YOU AS MUCH THANK. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE- IT'S OBVIOUSLY
CONCERN. WHEN MONEY THAT
REQUIRED TO BE USED FOR AND
ATTEND TO BE USED CERTAIN
SPECIALLY SUMPAH AS EVER
PROTECTION AND- WORKER BUT IS
NOT USE FOR THAT. RIGHT NOW- V.
ATTORNEY OFFICE HAS BEEN A TO
CONDUCT AN AND SO TO ABOUT. I
HAVE THE HONOR BEACON FOR HOW I
GET BRIEFED UP ON THAT IF
OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE THE TIME
TO MAKE THAT SWITCH RIGHT AND
TAKE ACTION CONSISTENT WITH MY
ABOUT. I APPRECIATE THAT THE
ARE. RESOURCES THAT CAN PUT TO
USE AND I THINK THAT WAS THE
POINT OF THE GROUP THAT I MET
WITH THIS MORNING AND THEIR
CONCERNS SO I APPRECIATE
YOU'RE- LOOKING INTO THAT THE
LAST QUESTION I HAVE BEFORE WE
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
REALLY HAS TO DO WITH
SOMETHING- I BROUGHT UP WHEN WE
HAD THE CONVERSATION- REALLY
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE AS THE COMMITTEE THAT
CONFIRMS- GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. HAVE MORE
RECENTLY- IT IS BEEN BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION ISSUES AROUND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND THE ROLE OF THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S. AS WE
LOOKED AT IN PARTICULAR-
APPOINTMENTS TO THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL. BOARD WE HAVE MORE
APPOINTMENTS COMING UP I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES KNOW THAT. AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WOULD BE CLARIFYING- FOR ALSO
OUR COLLEAGUES IN PARTICULAR
THE CHAIR OF THE BUSINESSES AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE ASKED
SENATOR ROTH. AS HE AND- AND
JOINTLY WITH THE ASSEMBLY
ADDRESS SUNSET REVIEW WHICH I
KNOW YOU'RE QUITE FAMILIAR
WITH. IS THE ISSUE. OF
CONSISTENCY THIS IS THE
QUESTION THAT CAME UP DURING B.
M. P. NOT IS DIRECTLY DURING
OUR PREVIOUS- COMMITTEE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS BUT IT
BECAME CLEAR BETWEEN THESE TWO
COMMITTEES. THAT THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION AROUND THE
CONSISTENCY OF GUIDELINES BEING
APPLIED- BY THE VARIOUS. DAGS
ARE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
FOR THESE CONSUMER PROTECTION
BOARDS. AND I JUST ALL LIE WE
HAD SOME CONVERSATION ALL I
REALLY WANT IS- YOUR COMMITMENT
THAT YOU WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE. AND RESPOND TO US
AND PARTICULARLY SENATOR ROTH-
FOR THE PROCESS THAT WERE IN TO
HELP MAKE OUR JOBS EASIER BUT
ALSO TO HAVE THAT ONGOING
DIALOGUE SO- IT'S ABOUT
CONSUMER PROTECTION SOMETHING I
KNOW YOU'RE COMMITTED. TO AND
YOUR OF BILL TO LOOK THAT IS.
AND ACT TO A THAT YOU WERE DO
THAT AND COMMUNICATE WITH US.
HI COMMITTEE THAT I WILL LOOK
INTO THAT AND COMMUNICATE WITH
YOU I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
THANK YOU FOR SHARING. YOUR
YOUR INTEREST AND CONCERN- I
I'VE DONE SOME ADDITIONAL
THINKING ABOUT IT SINCE. WE
SPOKE INCLUDING DOING SOME
RESEARCH INTO THAT THE NORTH
CAROLINA RULE THAT YOU THAT YOU
REFERENCED AND- IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALL FOLLOW THE SAME
RULES AND GUIDELINES AND LAWS
AND THAT'S BEEN CONSISTENTLY
APPLIED SO- I WILL GET WITH THE
APPROPRIATE PEOPLE AND
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE SHOULD I
HAVE THE HONOR BEING CONFIRMED
AND- CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU TO
COMMUNICATE- WHAT WE HAVE ON
THAT ISSUE. TRULY APPRECIATE
THAT- WITH THAT- I AM- WE
ALWAYS CAN CIRCLE BACK IF A IF
ANYONE HAS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS CAN WE GO THE PUBLIC
FIRST OKAY. THAT SOUNDS GREAT
SO- OKAY. I THINK WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO DO FOR OR SUPPORTED
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY OF
THE COMMITTEE- FOR SUPPORT OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER WE'RE GONNA
TAKE ABOUT A FIVE MINUTE BREAK.
AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU. THANK YOU.
ORDER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE AND YOUR PATIENCE. I
APPRECIATED WE ARE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND WE'RE
GONNA START ARE RIGHT HERE IN
THE. FOUR TWO OH THREE. AND I
DO SEE THAT WE HAVE SOMEONE
COMING DOWN TO SPEAK I WILL AS
YOU KNOW THE ROUTINE BY NOW
SINCE I RECOGNIZE YOU- MISTER
KAYLEE YOU NOTICE PROCREATIVE
SPIN SAYING EXCEPT FOR A- I
KNOW THAT YOU ARE AWARE SO WITH
THAT LET ME SAY WELCOME AND-
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
ORGANIZATION OF ANY REPRESENT
AND YOUR POSITION. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS ARE
CHRIS MAKAYLA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF YOUR-
CONFIRMATION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA TO BE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND CAN CERTAINLY. ATTEST
TO HIM BEING A CHAMPION FOR HIS
CONSTITUENTS THROUGHOUT THE
REGION- WE'RE VERY THANKFUL
THAT HE HAS ALWAYS WORKED TO
ENSURE THAT. OF MANY VOICES ARE
HEARD AND THAT HE CONSIDERS ALL
OPINION WHEN MAKING BIG PUBLIC
POLICY DECISIONS AND WE ARE
VERY CONFIDENT HE WILL MAKE A
WONDERFUL ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET ME SEE IF THERE IS
ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND AS YOU COME DOWN THANK YOU
I AM GOING TO I HAVE BEEN
ALERTED THAT WE HAVE A VERY
LARGE VOLUME OF PEOPLE WHO MAY
BE WANTING TO TESTIFY SO I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO GIVE YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT
IF ANY AN INCREDIBLY BRIEF
COMMENTS AS TO SUPPORT AND OF
COURSE WE GET OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION WELCOME. TIME SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
ALEX TAURUS WITH STRATEGIES TO
BE SIXTY PROUD TO BE HERE ON
BEHALF OF A COUPLE
ORGANIZATIONS TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MOMENTOUS
OCCASION UP PROUD TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
SOOMPI CALIFORNIA ASIAN CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE KIVA CONFECTIONS
EASE THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION
LEADER HEALTH HOUSING ACTION
COALITION SAN MANUEL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS AND TECHNET
ONCE AGAIN LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MR BONTA AND HIS
NEW CAPACITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE I GO
THE NEXT ROOM I'D LIKE TO KNOW
IF. FIRST IN ORDER FOR IS ABLE
TO HEAR THESE COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC. I THINK OUR I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT MIKE IS ON
OF A STRONG ENOUGH FOR PEOPLE
TO HEAR INCLUDING OUR
STENOGRAPHER SO. WE MAY TEST
THAT WHEN WE GET TO THE NEXT
MEMBER OF PUBLIC IF THERE IS
SOMEONE HERE. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- I MENTIONED THAT WE
HAD TWO ROOMS IN WHICH WE MAY
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC-
THAT WOULD BE THIS ROOM FOR TWO
OH THREE AND NOW I'M GOING TO
LOOK ON SCREEN TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE. WAITING WE DO NOT. SO
AT THIS POINT. C. N. NO MORE
WITNESSES IN EITHER ROOM WE
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. AND AS A REMINDER FOR
WITNESSES WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE TWO
SIX SIX ONE EIGHT EIGHT. SO
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAKIN SUPPORT. WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BONTA FOR ATTORNEY
GENERAL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
MADAM MODERATOR AS WE ARE
WAITING FOR THEM TO T. UP- WE
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME HEARING
YOU. SO YOU MAY WANT TO TEST
THAT ISSUE WELCOME THE FIRST
CALLER. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY
IS THAT BETTER. IT'S PATCHY ARM.
TRY AND TRY TO SAY HELLO AGAIN
MADAM MODERATOR AND LET US SEE
HOW THAT GOES. OUR FIRST MY
NUMBER. WILL BE LINE. SIXTEEN
WE- I THINK WE ARE HAVING A
DENTAL WE'RE GONNA PUT IT PUT
YOU ON HOLD A SECOND MADAME
MODERATOR WALL I HAVE R. I. T.
FOLKS CHECK. TO SEE IF WE CAN
HEAR YOU BETTER. OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS GO AHEAD AND GO FORWARD-
AND MADAME MODERATOR HI I WILL
JUST ASK YOU IF YOU COULD TO
PROJECT INTO YOUR MIKE AND WITH
THAT- I'M GOING TO REMIND OUR
WITNESSES THAT WE ASK YOU TO
SPEAK PROVIDE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND YOUR
SUPPORT BUT I AM GOING TO ASK
YOU TO GIVE YOUR SUPPORT AND-
NOT- SPEAK AT LENGTH BECAUSE WE
HAVE QUITE A NUMBER OF SPEAKERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY SO
WITH THAT MADAM MODERATOR GO
AHEAD WITH THE FIRST. LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MUCH MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BUT REALLY YOU ON
BEHALF YOU NEED A AFTER LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAVE A LONG CHAMP BERMAN
YEAH DEMONSTRATED OVER THE
YEARS TO COMMIT LET ME LET ME
ASK THIS TO STAY. AND ME TELL
MY STAFF THAT WE'RE BEING TOLD
WE CANNOT HEAR HER CLEARLY SO I
DON'T KNOW IF IT IS JUST THE
MODERATOR OR THE FIRST SPEAKER
WE NEED TO DOUBLE CHECK- SO
THAT WE CAN HEAR. PEOPLE I
APOLOGIZE. HOLD JUST A SECOND.
SENATOR VERY PATCHING. I THINK
OUR STENOGRAPHER IS SAYING THAT
IT IS PATCHY. OKAY SO ARE I. T.
FOLKS HAVE TRIED TO TURN IT UP
MORE LET ME GIVE THIS DIRECTION
WE WILL START AGAIN WITH THE
COLLAR ON ON THE LINE THAT THE
MODERATOR TEED UP. I'M GOING TO
ASK SPEAKERS TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND VERY CLEARLY INTO THEIR-
PHONE. SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AND I
WILL SEE IF WE'RE ABLE TO CATCH
YOUR COMMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- I APOLOGIZE SO
MUCH BUT WE WANT TO GET YOUR
TESTIMONY. AND WE ALSO WANT TO
BE ABLE TO PROCEED SO MADAM
MODERATOR LET'S TRY ONE MORE
TIME WELCOME THAT CALL OR ONE
MORE TIME. NINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS SO MUCH MADAM COULD HAVE
A MEMBER BEVERLY YOU ON BEHALF
OFYOU W. WHAT'S WRONG THE POOR
OF THE HISTORICAL TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND TAKE A FOR
YOUR YEAR TAL AND YOUR PATIENCE
MATAMATA NECK WITNESS. LINE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE KRISTEN BALBOA
ON BEHALF THE K. COAST
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG AND
PROUD SUPPORT. MR BONTA COME
FROM TO THE POSITION OF THE
TURN GENERAL AND GREAT FOR THE
MOM INSTEAD SUPPORT OF
BIPARTISAN CAN. PERF THANK YOU
MUCH THAT CAME ACROSS CLEARLY
NEXT WITH. MY FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
PAULA GAVEL FROM WIRE AMERICA
ROB IS A STAND GUY STAND WITH
FIRE AND WHAT THE ACTUAL SAME
EXACT BIG ENOUGH BE FIVE FIVE
SIX TWO TO ALL THE- DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WHY TODAY. DOES NOT
INCLUDE FIVE FIVE THREE YOU WE
WOULD YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MINDSET ONE YOU'RE MY IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
APPROACH EMPHASIS OBERNOLTE OR
BEHALF OF TELEPHONE AFTER THE-
ASSOCIATION HELLO GAPLESS
CLOSED PERSONALLY MUSICIANS IN
SUPPORT OF THE NOMINEE COME
MISTER BOND AND YEAR OF
HISTORIC FOR. THIS IS THIS A
GOOD NUMBER. SAMPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MY FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. ADAM
PRETENDING AND ANYMORE WEAPONS
GET FIRST. ASSEMBLY WE PRETTY
THAT LONG OF CANNING AFTER THEM
YOU DON'T HAVE A- AND THEN ON A
NOTE WITH MY HAD ON MY OWN IT'S
ONE OF HELP WE ARE. OF ON. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WHERE
MEMBERS JACKIE GRAY WALLET YET
WS CAPE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THE COMP OF ROB BONTA
AT ATTORNEY MR BONTA COMMITMENT
ACROSS INDEX UNDER PASSION
TWENTY TALIB RECORD APPLIQUE WE
KNOW WE CAN ON THE BONTA THE
PRODUCT AND THE FIRST NBA
CHAMPION BUT WORKING IF YOU
LOOK TO WITH THE BONTA I
CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITH
PLEASE. MIND YOUR IS OPEN
PLEASE AHEAD. ADAM CHEN MEMBER
OF THE SOVIET FROM THE SHOW ON
THE HIGH OF THE BUT TO NINE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE CAL
FACULTY THIRTEEN AND WE'RE IN
FRONT BAKER COME FROM OF THE
ASSEMBLY BOND AND CAL NECK
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NECK WITNESS.
MIND FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PROGRAM AND MEMBER ARE BACK
MARKET WEAPONS THE GREAT
CAMPAIGN AND THE FEDERAL AND
LAW PROGRAMS SUPPORT OF MR BY
COMP THAT OF OUTBOUND STATES
THAT GENERAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NECK WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE FOUR FIVE YOUR BY
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM
PROTECT MEMBERS IS MARTIN DR
SPEAKING ON OF FOLLOWING
MARKETING AND SUPPORT OF MR
POTTER. AND IT'S CALIFORNIA.
SUPER HABITAT FOR HUMANE CAL.
SANDHILL TMG PART. COULD SHE'D
CORRELATE AND THE BLACK LEADERS
COUNCIL ON IN STRONG. OF MR BY
COMP THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT WEEK. ROB BONTA FOR AGES
THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU%
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS PETER FLORENCE
JUNIOR THE PRESIDENT OF CHANGE
SHOULD BE ARMENIAN IT TO
REPRESENT ABOUT TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED ATTORNEYS INITIATIVE
LOCATED HERE AT OFFICERS WHAT'S
ONE OF THE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
LOOKS AND EXTREMELY CLEAN TO
ENDORSE SOME MEMBER BY.
COMMUNITY THE GENERAL. HEALTH
HIS LEGAL AND EFFORTS FOR ACT
INCOME ALREADY MAKE IT ONE OF.
WITH A COPY HE'LL MAKE A GREAT
YOU. FOR TO WORKING AS- TO MAKE
SURE THE PUBLIC PROFESSION OF
THE CHANGE ABOUT CARDS SUPPORT
AT COMPONENT PARTS WORK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. NINE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN EVAN ON
BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA RELATIVELY EVEN
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. BOARD OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PROTANDIM
MEMBERS I JUST RATTLED
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE PLEASED TO OFFER OUR
STRONG THE CORTLAND START
NOMINATION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB BONTA AT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN CANYON LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN IN ALL OF US ARE NINE.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ROB BONTA
FIRST CONFIRMATION CONNECTS AG-
WE GOT A REGION POSITIVE
HISTORY BURKE WITH THE SIMPLY
MEMBER BONTA. WE'RE
ORGANIZATION ANSWERED
COMMUNITIES IMPACTED BY THE
COMMERCIAL SYSTEM. SOME OF
THOSE FORMERLY INCARCERATED S.
B. BAR ORGANIZATION ANNOUNCED
THEY WERE QUITE OPEN ROB BONTA.
COMMITMENT TO THOSE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED INDIRECTLY IMPACTED.
THANK OF BURNING BRING NAY
GOING OUT COMPLAINTS ARE
CONCERNS IMPACT. YOU GOT TO
SPEAK IN ALL PLACES. I'M TO BE
ABLE ESCORT HIM TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. LINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KEVIN
MCCARTY I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS WE'RE
FROM MAINE CARS RATED INSISTING
IMPACTED STUDENTS WITH CHAPTERS
THAT YOU SEE CAMPUS WILL.
COMMAND YOU DONT BUT FIRST
COMMITMENT TO RACIAL AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND
SUPPORT APPOINTMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TELLING SENATORS BERNIE IS TO
RESTORE WITH THE WHITE OF IN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA SEIU CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU RANCHERIA
COUNTY INDIANS NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
GREEN ENERGY ON STRONG. SUPPORT
THE NOMINATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
ON BEHALF OF THE L. A. COUNTY
LABOR FEDERATION UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN THE TRANSPORT
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA AND
THE TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
WORKER CHAMPION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROB BONTA THANK YOU. YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SANDERS I AM
PROUD NO WHERE IN SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF JAMES W. AT
WORK SHARE OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATIONS AND ALSO C. E. O.
OF THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION. MR ABOUT HIS
DISTRICT THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION
IS VERY PLEASED TO BE
SUPPORTING THE NOMINATION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA TO
BECOME CALIFORNIA'S NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON PAMELA
LOPEZ WITH KATE ST CONSULTING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NORMAL
WE ARE SO PROUD TO BE
SUPPORTING THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA CHU I
AG AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU TO
ADDRESS THE INJUSTICES THAT
HAVE BEEN. PERPETUATED BY THE
WAR ON DRUGS- HELLO HAS ALSO
ITS PRESIDENT OF WORK ACT WOULD
BE AT SO TRY TO WORK WITHIN
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT VALUES-
GENDER EQUITY IN THE WORKPLACE-
IN A TRUE. ALLY ON WOMEN'S
ISSUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERYMUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
NINE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE JASON
BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
UNITED DAIRIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH A SETTLEMENT OVER THE
YEARS AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. MR BONTA IS NOMINATION
AND CONFIRMATION TO BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. FIND
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JOSH FINEST WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION IS
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ESTEBAN UNIONS AND PAYMENT OF
THE INTEREST OF THE COLLISION
IN STRONG SUPPORT- IN OUR NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JACK EVEN
BOTHERED IMMIGRATION POLICY
DIRECTOR CALL YOU JUMPED ON THE
NUMBER OF CONTACTS. ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING. WITH YOU THE NUMBER.
BEEN THERE TO GET THE POP AND
AT THE CRITICAL TO PROTECT
INTEGRITY. THERE A VERY
KNOWLEDGE OF BECAUSE LOOK AT
THE ALL WE NEED MAYOR HELLO
MA'AM I'M SO SORRY BOB YOU SLOW
A LITTLE BIT SO WE CAN SURE AND
YOUR TEST I APOLOGIZE. IF THE
HIPSTER MOMENT NOT JUST FOR
PHILIP COMMUNITY ARKAN. FOR
COLOR PARTICULARLY IN THE- ON
OUR NEXT. HAS AND ACT. FOR THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY AND CAL.
BOB HAVE NOW BECOME MAN MY
BILLS AND BE REPLICATE BY OTHER
STATE HE HAD COMPLETE. THANK.
OKAY OUR IN THE COUNTRY OF THE
LAW I. FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
WE CONGRATULATE HIM AND FORWARD
WORKING WITH YOU YOUR CAPACITY
AS QUICKLY CONNECTED GENERAL
CAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NINE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM FOR TAM AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS JOHN LEVEL AND I'VE
BEEN ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
LOBBYISTS AT THE CAPITOL
INSTEAD OF HIM FOR THE LAST
THIRTY SIX YEARS AND- I WORKED-
WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ANNOUNCING THE MEMBER BONTA
WHEN HE WAS DEVELOPING MAKING
AND I WERE WORKING ON THE
MEDICAL CANNABIS. LEGISLATION
THE VERY FIRST ONE ENACTED AT
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW- BUT
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW CAN
RESULT IN DISCUSSION THAT
EVOKES AN EVEN BETTER WORK
PRODUCT. SIMPLY MR BONTA
EXEMPLIFIES WITH VERY HIGH
STANDARDS OF PUBLIC SERVICE- A
LAWYER'S LAWYER YES ON.
SHIPBUILDING AND HAS A- TO POP
SERVICE. PLEASE. YET ALMOST
CREAMY LIKE HAVING. CREATING.
CLEARING OUT THAT COULD- I
JUST- I'M VERY VERY YOU KNOW
TO- COULD SUPPORT HIS. IT'S
GONE COULD MAKE WE WILL BE A
TRULY. ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK NEXT
WITNESS. NINE TWO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I ASK WORN WITH
THE CAL FOR J. AND- WE'RE A
COMMUNITY BASED ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION BASED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN IN COACHELLA VALLEY
FOCUSED ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CLIMATE CHANGE CLEAN
ENERGY ACT THAT TRANSPORTATION
DRINKING WATER. OR IN THE PART
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF ROB
BONTA FOR CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM TO REALIZE
THAT MARK JEFF CALIFORNIA.
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BATUM PRETENDING
MEMBERS ONLY FEARLESS FROM
GLUCOSE STRATEGY CHEN MY OWN
CAPACITY SHOSHAN SUPPORT FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF A FAMILY
MEMBER BONTA AND OUR NEXT
ATTORNEY GENERAL OVER THE YEARS
WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ON HEALTH CONSUMER PROTECTION
AND WOMEN'S EQUITY ISSUES. I
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE
AND KNOW HIM LIKE YELP AND.
ENGAGING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM PROTECTING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALKA MCCARTY AND I'M
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
APPOINTMENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB
BONTA THAT SERVE OUR DIVERSE
STATE OF THE NEXT CHANGE I'M
NOT SURE WE CAN MANAGED
ADVOCATE FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS ALWAYS BEEN POSSIBLE
DELIVERY. ABOUT THE COURAGE TO
EDUCATION PROGRAMS INCLUDING
MANAGED AM I. WE KNOW WE CAN
ALWAYS COUNT ON MR BONTA DEMAND.
RIGHT ON. THE IMAGE OF ON IT
BEST TWENTY SEVENTEEN. OF
GENERAL. MOTORS CALL YET
BECAUSE- VERY. WE DO THE JOB
THANK YOU. NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND IS PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS NOMINATION OF A CHAMPION
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM IT
WAS INVESTMENT. IN SHIPS THAT
ARE. BONTA DIMINISH CRITICAL IT
UP BUILDING OUR STAGE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RECORDS SYSTEM WHAT WAS
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE. AS
WELL AS LEADING ON BILL REFORM
BANNING PRIVATE PRISONS
PROTECTING IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
AND ADVOCATING CONCURRENCE WITH
INDIVIDUALS. WITH KNOWLEDGE
FROM THE PENDANT. AND THAT'S
THE FIRST. RIGHT ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND. BUT BUT IT'S LONG
BURNERS AND- THE FIRST DAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM IS
WE GO TO THE NEXT WITNESS I AM
GOING TO ADD THE WHICH TO GIVE
YOUR NAME NOW YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND THAT JUST
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE NOMINEE I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE ALL OF THE
TIME TO HEAR FROM EVERYBODY
EXTENSIVELY BUT BY MR BONTA
ALSO HAS A DATE WITH THE
ASSEMBLY. THIS EVENING AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR EVERYONE TO
STATE THEIR NAME AND POSITION
SO I AM GOING TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE FORCEFUL THAN I HAVE
BEEN BUT IN FAIRNESS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE REST OF THE
PROCESS. I WANT EVERYBODY TO
GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN
SO YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
MODERATOR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRIAN
LUNDGREN A PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA CARDROOM. A POINT
THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
SETTLEMENT ROB BONTA ATTORNEY
GENERAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT WAS PERFECT
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT. OH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. A LINE SIXTY EIGHT IS
NO LONGER IN THE QUEUE ONE
SIXTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX
OSBORN AT THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HERE TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB
BONTA AS OUR NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. NINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA SISTAR
CONFIRMATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. LINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL TOGETHER WHY AMERICA POINT
OF ORDER WHAT BILL WILL BE
REFERRED AFTER THAT IT DOES NOT
SAY ON THE AGENDA. THANK YOU-
ARE ARE YOU CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF MR BONTA. WE DO SUPPORT MR
BONTA BUT WE DO NEED
CLARIFICATION ON YOUR AGENDA
THAT THAT THAT ITEM SIR HAS
ALREADY BEEN MOVED EARLIER IN
THE MEETING AND I WILL REFER
YOU TO THE WEBSITE OR TO. THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES FOR SPECIFIC
REAL NUMBER SO WITH THAT. THANK
YOU NUMBER THE BILL PLEASE MAY
YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE NUMBER
THE BILL SERVER. NEXT YEAH I'M
GONNA GO TO THE NEXT CALL
PLEASE CONTACT THE RULES
COMMITTEE WE WILL GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION- MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITH. AND I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER AND MADAME MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ARE
NOT AN IMPORTANT MEMBER BACK ON
TOP OF SILICON VALLEY
CAMPGROUND. SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
OUR OUR LAST COMMENT IN QUEUE
IS NINE SEVENTY FIVE POINT
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME AT THE TOP WITH
RESOLUTE ON BEHALF OF THE COULD
HE HAD TRIED THE VA HAS TRIED
AND THE HAVE THAT MUCH OLD
ALMOST UPPER LAKE TRIED.
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE CONFIRMATION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB BONTA AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOB MAHER
MODERATOR ONE LAST CHECK FOR
ANY REMAINING CALLS IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE QUEUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND WE SO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND WORKING WITH US ON
OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES WE WILL
BE BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY-
AND FOR NOW I'M GOING TO COME
BACK INTO A ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
THOSE IN SUPPORT WE ARE NOW
GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL FOLLOW
THAT SAME PROCESS AS WE HEAR
FROM THOSE INDIVIDUALS SO WE'LL
BEGIN AGAIN WITH PEOPLE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. IN OPPOSITION. OKAY I
SEE NO ONE STEPPING FORWARD AT
THIS TIME HI IN ROOM FOUR TWO
OH THREE SO I'M GOING TO TURN
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. OUR SECOND
ROOM. I SEE NO ONE APART
APPROACHING THE PODIUM- IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND WITH THAT MADAME
MODERATOR WE ARE BACK WITH YOU
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC VIA
TELECONFERENCE THAT WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
COULD- GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING IN THE QUEUE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE ONE PARTICLE. WE
HAD ONE PARTY AND THEY HAVE- NO
LONGER THEY'RE NO LONGER TO
DEATH BUT IF I MAY OF PROVIDE
THE- ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
THE CONFIRMATION OF ROB BONTA.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE CONFIRMATION
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. MAN MODERATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I'M SORRY WE DO
HAVE TWO PARTIES THAT DID QUEUE
UP ONE MOMENT OKAY THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS SAMPLE RATE
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF GUN
OWNERS CALIFORNIA AND IN ORDER
TO KEEP A- LOOK AT THE TIME
SHORT I'M ALSO. RISE SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION
AND WE HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY.
OPPOSE THE UP THE- APPOINTMENT
OF A CINNAMON BONTA AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL WE KNOW WE CANNOT STOP
THEM. MYSTERY IS THAT WE'VE HAD
A RATHER CONTENTIOUS
RELATIONSHIP LEGISLATIVELY
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER- WITH
REGARDS O GUN CONTROL MATTERS.
AND THAT'S ATTORNEY GENERAL
HE'S GOING TO BE IN A PLACE OF
ENFORCING MANY OF THE LAWS AND
OUR HOPE IS THAT HE WILL KEEP.
THE COMMITMENTS THAT HE MAY TWO
TWO. SENATORS GROGAN BATES IN
AN OPENING BEING OPEN TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
WE KNOW THERE WILL BE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION- BUT
THAT WOULD BE. FAR BETTER
SITUATION WE HAD WITH THE
PREVIOUS. COUPLE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S AND- THERE ARE MANY
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE
NEED TO DISCUSS WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS. WITH THE- CINNAMON
BONTA AP IS APPOINTED-
CONFIRMED AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SO WITH THOSE- BUT- WITH THAT
RATIONALE. WE ARE THE
NOMINATION FOR THE RECORD. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL. ODD
NEXT WEEK. NINE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ALFRED MORRIS AND- WE MISSED
THE SUPPORT PART SO HOPEFULLY
WE CAN CHIME IN THERE SO I'M
HAPPY CAL NATIONS INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION IN. NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN MEMBERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHAT ALSO THE ARMENIAN TRAINED
AND LABOR. FROM INSTRUCTORS. OF
MR BONTA BEING CONFIRMED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SLIPPED IN UNDER THE WIRE
MADAME MODERATOR ANY FURTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME AGAIN LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR PATIENCE WITH US TODAY I'M
GOING TO BRING IT BACK INTO.
ATTY EXCUSE ME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR FURTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. I WOULD JUST MAKE
THE COMMENT THAT I THINK THIS
IS A HISTORIC APPOINTMENT OF
THE JUDGMENT OF THE GOVERNOR
WAS VALIDATED BY THE EXCHANGES
WE'VE HAD TODAY IT WAS GOOD TO
GET ON THE RECORD OF THE NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
I THINK HE'S GONNA MAKE A GREAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND WHENEVER
IT'S APPROPRIATE I'M GOING TO
MAKE A MOTION. SENATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MEDEVACED HERE.
YES IT IS A HISTORICAL
APPOINTMENT AND I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA. FOR BEING
A VERY TRANSPARENT VERY FORTH
COMING AND ALL THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT ON
FROM THESE VERY. DIFFICULT
ISSUES THAT WE ALL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH. I AM GOING TO ABSTAIN
TODAY- I WILL PURSUE ON MORE
INFORMATION NOW BEFORE WE GET
TO THE FINAL VOTE. BUT I DO
WANT TO SAY I TRULY APPRECIATE
OF THE MANNER IN WHICH YOU HAVE
THE DRAFT THE QUESTIONS. THAT
HAVE ON AND I THINK THE MANNER
IN WHICH THE QUESTIONS ROUSE
WERE NOT SO CONFRONTATIONAL IF
THEY WERE SINCERE. IN IN
DIGGING INTO WHERE YOU STAND ON
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE VERY VERY VERY
CHALLENGING FOR YOU. IF YOU
TAKE THIS VERY IMPORTANT
POSITION FOR CERTAINLY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU TO YOUR
FAMILY FOR BEING HERE TO
SUPPORT YOU IT'S WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU ALL. AND WILLOW. WILL
STAY IN TOUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR- CENTER
CONQUER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS I
THINK- THAT THE GOVERNOR. WAS
SO ASTUTE IN HIS APPOINTMENT OF
YOU FOR. THIS POSITION AND I
KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN A
STRONG CHAMPION. OUT WHEN IT
COMES TO. WORKERS RIGHTS
CONSUMER RIGHTS FOCUSING ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM HEALTH
CARE REFORM. SUPPORTING THE
ENVIRONMENT- YOU HAVE BEEN
THERE AND I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO YOUR LEADERSHIP- COMING
FROM- THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND THE AG'S OFFICE. I
JUST ALSO WANT TO REITERATE.
HOW IMMENSELY PROUD SO MANY OF
MY CONSTITUENTS ARE. OF YOU AND
THIS APPOINTMENT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT AND I HOPE THAT YOU FEEL
IT- SO MANY FOLKS SAID THIS IS
SOMEONE THAT YOU WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS IS OUR TIME WE
REALLY WANT BONTA TO BE
APPOINTED. SO THAT WE HAVE A
VOICE. AS A FILIPINO AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE HAVE A
VOICE. I KNOW IT PUTS LOTS OF
PRESSURE ON YOUR SHOULDERS BUT
I ALSO KNOW THAT YOUR SHOULDERS
ARE VERY STRONG. AND CAN HANDLE
THE WEIGHT SO I AM VERY EXCITED
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
AND FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SENATOR- LET ME JUST-
ADD- MY INCREDIBLE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU TO YOUR
SPOUSE YOUR DAUGHTER'S. YOUR
ENTIRE FAMILY YOUR MOM AND DAD-
IT IS I AGREE WITH THE SENATOR
COM LONGER IT ISN'T. AWESOME
OPPORTUNITY IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
HISTORIC MOMENT BUT IT IS-
CERTAINLY- YOU WILL BEAR THE
WEIGHT OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN ON
YOUR SHOULDER I KNOW I IN ALL
OF THE INCREDIBLE DIVERSITY.
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT WE
REFLECT I APPRECIATE THE TIME
WE HAVE SERVED TOGETHER I
APPRECIATE THE FOUNDATION THAT
WE HAVE LAID- AND WHEN WE HEAR
ALL OF THE QUESTIONS- WHEN I
SAID THOUGHT FULL COULD LEAD
YOU'LL UNDERSTAND THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE QUESTIONS-
THAT WERE PLACED BEFORE YOU- I
THINK I THINK YOU- RESPONDED
WITH THE RESPECT OF THE OF EACH
QUESTION AND I SO APPRECIATE
THAT THAT IS WHAT WE NEED IN
THIS DAY AND TIME.
THOUGHTFULNESS CONSIDERATION
RESPECT FOR EVERY PERSON AND SO
IT REALLY IS AN HONOR TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF YOU TODAY AGAIN
AND WE WISH YOU ALL THE BEST
AND JUST REMEMBER THAT THE
SENATE WAS VERY KIND TO YOU- AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE- I
KNOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS- AND THAT
FOUNDATION THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT WE LAID WILL BE THE BASIS
OF HOW WE COMMUNICATE GOING
FORWARD WHETHER ON PIECES OF
LEGISLATION. OR BUDGET ISSUES
OR POLICY ISSUES AND HOW WE
WORK TOGETHER ON SOLUTIONS AND
TO GET THE JOB DONE. SO VERY
HONORED AND WITH THAT US
SENATOR LAYER DUE TO LOOK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DO IT AGAIN OUR
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB BONTA TO BE
THE NEXT ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
VERY ELOQUENTLY DONE MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER YES
KAMLAGER HI LAYERED. I BATES
BATES NOT VOTING ATKINS AYE
ATKINS AYE ON AND WE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN- BECAUSE SENATOR
BROKE IS IT HEALTH BUT YOU HAVE
THREE VOTES WHICH IS
APPROPRIATE TO MOVE THIS
CONFIRMATION FORWARD TO THE
FLOOR CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
SO MUCH MATTER PROTON SENATE
DEBATE CENTER LAYERED CENTER
COME UNDER YOUR WORDS ARE
INCREDIBLY KIND INCREDIBLY
GENEROUS I APPRECIATE ALL OF
THEM APPRECIATE OUR DIALOGUE.
I'M TO DO MY BEST TO MAKE MY
FAMILY ALL OF YOU AND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA PROP THANK YOU
FOR. VERY WELL THANK YOU. GOOD
LUCK. AND WITH THAT ONE I'M
GOING TO SIT HERE AND HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES I WILL ADJOURN AFTER
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO VOTE. K.
CEMENTUM SECRETARY- WILL YOU
CALL THE- CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
NOT THIRTEEN GROVE NOT VOTING
THREE DESERVES THANK YOU THAT
IS THREE IN SUPPORT TO
ABSTENTIONS AND WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES IN
PARTICULARLY YOU FOR RUNNING
BACK AND FORTH WITH THAT THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.